ch
the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne who mov
house adjourned from the session of
January 3rd 2024 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
APPA n eyes have it in the house
journ the house will attend to a Prayer
by representative Alexis
Simpson good
morning let us be in a spirit of
prayer source of our Eternal hope be
present in this
moment as we come together to work for
the good of the people of New Hampshire
keep us mindful of our own
Humanity keep us mindful of the deep
connection that joins us all together as
our feet all walk on the same
ground may we remain mindful of the
those who are sick hungry or
suffering be a comfort and a healing
presence to all those who need that
today may we bring our thoughts to a
peace that passes all understanding as
we begin our day this
morning
amen the chair recognizes a member from
Hillsboro represent Rich colomi who will
lead us in a pledge of
allegiance of the United States of
America and to the for it stands one
nation indivisible with liy and justice
for
all the chair and now recognizes Addison
cutter of antrum who will sing our
national
anthem
oh say can you
[Music]
see by the dawn
early
light what so
proudly we
ha at the
Twilight last
gleaming who who brought stripes and
bright
[Music]
stars through the
perous
fight or the ramp part we
watch were so
gantly
streaming and the
rocky the bombs
bursting in air
gave Pro through the
night that our flag was still
there oh say does that star
spangled
b or the land of the
[Music]
free and the
home of of
Love
[Applause]
[Music]
bra
please turn on your voting
stations as a reminder uh please turn on
all your voting
stations the house will attend to
request for leaves of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives boras Ellison Gibbons
lungren Ryan Tetro and tensar the day
important business Representatives Buco
con sanbor Traer and
vanney these leads of absent shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house the house will attend to the
introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome Erica
Jacob Jameson and Alice cutter Don and
David Pothier Jerry Gardia and lindsy
gioino family and friends of the singer
guests of Representative kcom Karen Leo
Hill guest of Representative Aly and Sam
Fairington guest of Representative duet
they are with us in the gallery
today welcome to your
[Applause]
house house will now attend to the
continuation of the regular calendar
beginning with Senate Bill 263
FN
maity
the majority of committee on finance to
which was referred Senate Bill 263 FN an
act extending New Hampshire Granite
Advantage healthc Care Program
reestablishing the commission to
evaluate the effectiveness and future of
New Hampshire Granite Advantage Health
Care Program consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
presentative Morin Mooney for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the
committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Mary Jane
walner from the minority of the
committee the chair recognizes
representative
Stringham thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning
everybody I'm honored to speak with you
uh about an effective program the
granted advance manage program and this
important bill uh for the past 8 years
Medicaid expansion has provided Primary
Care preventative Services and Specialty
Care to low-income residents and workers
contributing to a healthier and stronger
Workforce while reducing uncompensated
care costs and thereby reducing
insurance rates in the individual Market
SB 263 permanently extends this proven
program
it received strong support from the
business Community the medical community
upon its introduction in the Senate and
that body passed this bill on a
unanimous bipartisan
vote the presentation of this bill to
the Health and Human Services committee
was overwhelmingly positive with over 30
members of the public speaking on behalf
of the bill and only one
opposing after voting down an amendment
to only temporarily extend the program
the house voted 193 that's this house to
166 to pass the same legislation on May
18th it was subsequently referred to
finance committee and retained following
its retention in house finance a 7-year
extension of the granted Advantage was
enacted as part of the budget Bill and
therefore the fiscal impact of this
legislation is already fully accounted
for in the state
budget how much does business like this
bill
the business and industry Association
the Bia put this bill this exact bill on
its report card recently were published
in the legislative report card which was
distributed with a New Hampshire
Business Review a vote for this bill
gave a representative a positive check
mark from the Bia a no vote gives you
the opposite business wants this bill to
pass some of my colleagues have Express
concerns about long-term costs what if
the federal government reduces the 90%
cost of the program this point was even
mentioned in the
blur it turns out that we in New
Hampshire have already accounted for
that one of my colleagues said there are
no triggers in the program read the law
well while the RSA is silent on issue
the accompanying chapter law includes a
provision that protects tax taxpayers
against this event let me read you the
past Mage from current law
342 section 12 New Hampshire Granite
Advantage Health Care Program Federal
match if at any time the federal match
applied to medical assistance for newly
eligible adults under RSA 126 AA is less
than 90% in 2020 or any year thereafter
which the program is authorized then the
program is hereby repealed 100
80 days after this event under this
paragraph uh the commissioner shall in
this event within 48 hours after the
event under this paragraph has occurred
notify the governor the speaker to the
House of Representatives the president
of the Senate and the chairperson of the
legislative fiscal Committee of the
program's pending
termination and within 10 days after the
event has occurred notify program
participants of the program's pending
termination uh OSS has
confirmed that this text remains part of
current
law some feel the US Congress will
surely reduce the 90% Federal share well
we'll see but you should be in mind that
the federal government requires
accredited hospitals to provide care to
patients regardless of their insurance
status because of that the rates that
the federal government pays through the
Medicare program take takes into account
the amount of uncompensated care that
hospitals absorb this formula for
Hospital specific payment uh depends on
the amount of care and the factor is
called disproportionate
share because New Hampshire instituted
the granted Healthcare Advantage Program
the amount of the uninsured shortfall
has declined dramatically in
2014 the amount of uninsured shortfall
was 173 million in the latest year that
we have data fiscal year
2222 it was 67 million a decrease of
about 70% any reduction in participation
from from States will result in
increased uncompensated Care and More
payments through the disproportionate
share formula so there's a lot of
incentive to keep it where it is but if
I'm Incorrect and the federal government
reduces their share even with this bill
passing we will immediately have some
work to do do together and figure out
how to respond because of the
trigger s sp263 is sound policy and
should again pass this house removing
the sunset which effectively that's what
passing s sp263 will do allows providers
to build the infrastructure and attack
attract the workforce necessary to meet
our state's needs improving quality of
care for
everybody there's some risks businesses
can live with but pending sunset on a
law that may lead a future program
discontinuance removes incentives to
build the infrastructure to make the
program work as well as it can I mean we
work well together now but you the
future legislatures 5 years from now
might not love each other as much as we
do so and businesses suspect that's the
case and to lose a key part of their
investment because there's a political
stalemate in a future legislature would
it discourage the necessary Investments
now there are sufficient triggers in the
current law through the RSA and chapter
law to permanently protect taxpayer
interest there will still be bills in
future terms to amend or change the
program just like every other program we
have the medical community the business
community and the Senate were wise to
overwhelmingly support this bill as were
we so please join me to vote no on the
itl motion so that an ought to pass
motion the house senate business
community and medical community
supported bill can be voted on thank
thank
you chair recognize representative
Edwards
uh
what I I don't know what you're saying
to
me hey he can
speak did you call me up yes yeah all
right that's what we have
here I I think my vice chair would like
to speak instead I don't mind deferring
to him I know this is a
problem come on
up come on
up chair recognizes representative
Earth
thank you Mr
Speaker so I'm going to end up
where the gentleman before me started I
mean uh yes started we should not make
Medicaid expansion permanent for able
bodied residents until we confirm this
is the most coste effective way to
handle uncompensated care costs the
program was intended to be less costly
than since the program's Inception we
haven't had a good good basis on what on
which to do this
comparison most recently during Co the
federal government prevented anyone who
became unqualified to be on Medicaid to
be removed from the program this drove
up
costs only this past spring did the
requirement lapse at which time the
state could begin removing unqualified
recipients from the roles this process
is still
ongoing another issue in looking at
costs is that the Medicaid expansion
program has been off budget since its
Inception and funded by a changing array
of dedicated revenue streams and I'm
going to come back to that one of these
in particular in just a
moment this is in contrast to the larger
Medicaid Program which is part of our bu
anal budgeting
process we in this house put the program
onto the budget when we passed our
budget in the
spring but the other body again removed
it per our Department of Health and
Human
Services the 7year extension now in law
allows for good
competition between Managed Care
organizations bidding on the contract
renewal in the coming
year if we work to get the program on
budget in the near future we can better
analyze the costs of a new competitively
bid contract and now I'll come to where
we have a pretty firm
disagreement a final
concern is there was a trigger in the
early version of the program that would
terminate the program if the federal
government changed the cost sharing
ratio this trigger was removed in 2019
2020 now I'll be a little more precise
here with the word removed what happened
was they so back to the revenue
streams it's an
everchanging uh set of guaranteed
revenue streams that fund this program
one of them is funding from The Liquor
Commission and what was and the Liquor
Commission has generally put in about 5%
of
their uh revenues and then if there was
a underfunding they would top it up
to uh take care of the underfunding what
was changed was that was set up that the
trigger now is if the lier commission
runs out of
money then the program will be
terminated
now if the liquid commission runs out of
money the government is
gone just so we're
clear so this means a potent the
potential for this changing on the
federal government's part of of the
sharing means a potentially large
increase in costs to the
state oh as they've done in the past the
federal government has changed a lot of
program matches as with the Medicaid and
others um and child
uh special education is another very
good example of that where they
initially funded it very highly and then
they reduced that uh down so please
voting please join me in voting in favor
of the itl thank you Mr Speaker does the
member yield to questions no member does
not
yield representative Granger has weall
for has called for a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
e
the motion before us is a majority
committee report of itl on Senate Bill
263 this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative Weber for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know the passage of this
bill will have no effect on this budget
or the next budget or the budget after
that after which we will have plenty
give information about where we're
at because we've been doing this program
for a long time now and we keep hearing
we don't know
enough and if I
know that more than
individuals businesses and medical care
providers came to us and begged us to
make this change permanent
because it's the best thing for Granite
State
individuals businesses and Health
Care would I now press the green
button oh
sorry it had to
happen would I now this is why I get by
with a Little Help from My Friends would
I now press the red button to overturn
the itl so another ma motion can be
made you'll remember it now and so will
I J recognizes representative Mooney for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning members of the New Hampshire
house if I know that after careful
discussion debate and
negotiation seven years was agreed upon
in the state budget last year for
Medicaid expansion it is current law and
if I know that the state budget that was
including the seven-year Medicaid
expansion passed on a historic Voice
vote last
spring lastly if I know that a 7-year
renewal and review of a contract and
program of this
importance of this magnitude is the
responsible and prudent path
forward then would I join the majority
of the house finance committee and vote
green to pass the itl motion thank you
motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisla Senate Bill 263 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor faor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote
how you have to give me a thumb
Sor have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 191 voting yay 183 voting a the
committee report is adopted
for what reason does a member rise uh to
make a motion State your motion uh
having voting on the prevailing side I
move to reconsider and I urge the body
to vote
no the motion is to Recon reconsider on
Senate Bill
263 a division has been
requested I would assume all members are
in still in their
seats
clear motion before us is
reconsideration on Senate Bill
263 if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
repres all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 180 3 voting aay 193 voting aay
reconsideration
fails majority committee on finance to
which was referred Senate Bill 267
FN house will be in
order an act requiring the commissioner
of the Department of Environmental
Services to consider cultive impacts
analysis in rules and statutes having
considered the same Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate pres of Joe
Sweeney for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass repres of Karen eel for the
minority of the
committee the chair recognizes
representative
eel
thank you Mr chair I mean Mr Speaker
that's not a good way to start out um
and lest I forget I'd like to request a
division
vote okay SB 267 if passed would
authorize the expenditure of
approximately
$250,000 to hire a Dees staff person to
study the issue of cumulative impacts in
facility pollutant permitting such as
the permitting of landfills which emit
methane and other landfill gases or
industries by reviewing new hampire law
and researching possible
Alternatives after a two-year study Dees
would report its findings and
recommendations back to the legislature
unless SB 267 is passed Dees does not
have the funding the staff or the
expertise to do this important research
it's important to note that Dees is not
authorized to put any law into place or
take any affirmative action on its own
by this bill any further action would be
left up to the
legislature
$250,000 is a modest amount of money to
be appropriated considering what is at
stake and that is the health of our
citizens which is
invaluable New Hampshire can certainly
afford this expense at this time the
policy position of the house is very
clear the environment and agriculture
committee recommended passage
unanimously and this body passed s SP
267 by a very strong bipartisan vote of
302 to 77 we are only deciding on the
issue of money today and as we heard
yesterday there is Surplus and we can
afford it
$250,000 is a small fraction of even the
50 million we decided to um put forward
on retirement yes yesterday this
expenditure is common sense under
current law facilities emitting
pollutants hazardous to our health are
assessed individually and licensed
accordingly this siloed approach to
permitting ignores all the other
pollutants that may be present in the
surrounding air water and soil take for
instance a company that uses a product
like PAC in
manufacturing most recently such a
company was granted a permit that
allowed the release of a certain amount
of past into the air something many here
have grave concerns about under a
cumulative impacts analysis Dees would
look not only at the in entity seeking
the permit but also at other pollutants
in the area when it's going through the
licensing process so just as an example
because this can get confusing let's say
that by law the maximum amount of a
toxic substance like sulfur dioxide that
one company can release per year into
the air is 500 PBS and let's say that
company X has gotten an air permit
allowing it to release 500 pounds of
sulfur dioxide a year which is the mult
maximum allowable and then company Z
moves into the same area and it's also
permitted to release the same amount
because Dees will only look at What that
particular facility would emit during
the year so no company could be
permitted to emit a th000 pounds but two
can taken together I don't know about
you but I wouldn't want to live in the
air in the area that released that much
of the uh pollutant into the air so
shouldn't we at least take a look at our
laws and see if this approach makes
sense it certainly raises questions this
bill is fiscally responsible and yes the
budget process has passed but we're
going to be talking about many bills
that have Appropriations this ter this
term it's not like this will be out of
the ordinary and yes Dees has unrelated
staff positions to fill but so do many
stat agencies that's no reason to itl
this bill ultimately we could save far
more by spending
$250,000 now including on healthc care
and Remediation costs using a more
comprehensive approach to permitting and
we'll never know what opportunities are
available if we don't appropriate this
money at this
time I know many of us here are no great
fans of government
regulations and I don't but I don't
think anyone wants to be drinking lead
or drinking pasas in their water
sometimes environmental regulations are
needed to protect the public health and
the health of our loved ones and our
children please join me in pushing the
red button overturning this itl motion
so we can give DS the ability to study
the cumulative impacts possibilities and
then we as a body can decide how we want
to move forward on the best research
available it's worth the money and uh Mr
Speaker I request a division vote thank
you you recognize representative
Sweeny thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning to my colleagues Senate Bill 267
appropriates
$250,000 to force Dees to hire an
additional state employee to study
cumulative impact analysis I'm not going
to touch onto the slippery slope that is
the policy part of this debate and
really just stick to the financials this
is money that Dees did not request in
their budget the governor did not
request in his version of the budget
when we worked on the budget Dees in
front of us did not ask us to put this
money into the budget the other body
where this bill originated from after
passing it on to us did not see the need
or the want to put it into their version
of the budget and when we vote Voice
voted our Miracle state budget last last
year we did not have this money in the
budget there is a huge slippery slope of
adding state government employee
positions after the fact on top of the
budget after we we had passed it
expending more funds uh to study an
issue we have a system in place of which
we study issues that are coming before
the legislature for future rules and
future laws that is our responsibilities
we do not Outsource that to unelected
bureaucrats that's not what we're here
to do so I urge you to vote with the
committee on inexpedient to legislate
let's stop you know
$250,000 here $250,000 there eventually
we are talking about real money uh for
the citizens of new Hampshire that are
paying these taxes so let's be fiscally
prudent let's vote green today on the
itl motion thank you very
much the motion before us is the in
majority committee report of inut legisl
sener Bill
uh representative eel and representative
Sweeney both request that a division
vote so we will have a division vote
members take your
seats
[Music]
e
clear motion before as majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on sen Bill 267 this is a
division vote chair recognizes
representative leechman for a
parliamentary
inquiry good morning Mr speaker thank
thank
you Mr Speaker if I know that the
environment and agriculture committee
voted 19 to Zer to support this
legislation and if I know that we do
have a State budgetary Surplus that
could easily afford the
$250,000 in this
request and I know that this would
support the Department of Environmental
Services review of future
recommendations to the legislature and
whether leg leg islation is in fact
needed concerning cumulative
environmental impacts and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that more information
leads to better decisions when it comes
to Public Health wouldn't I press the
red button and overturn this motion of
itl so a motion of ought to pass could
be offered thank
you chair recognize representative wlo
for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the primary task
of a legislature is to set clear and
well-defined limits to a proposal and
lacking those limits a law becomes
ineffective and results in constant
litigation this proposal opens the door
for Dees to constantly find ways to
expand as cumulative impact is a totally
subjective phrase that could never see a
limit as to what an opponent could
imagine please press the green button we
don't need these phony
phrases the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on Senate Bill
267 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations open for 30
seconds
represent
Bo represent
Gallagher have all members present had
an opportunity to vote house will attend
to state of the
vote 189 to 188 I did not
vote committee report is
adopted
committee on Health and Human Services
elderly Affairs to which is referred
House Bill 264 FN relative to amendments
and corrections to birth records comes
to us without recommendation
representative Canon moves ought to pass
Sher andiz as representative
kishman good morning thank you Mr
speaker thank you colleague Coles uh the
United Kingdom started the global trend
of formalizing vital records in the
1850s um and they started with birth
certificates the reason given for this
move was for improved documentation for
the large amount of immigrants that were
moving across the Atlantic as well as
getting a better understanding of
population demographics and monitoring
National Public Health
Trends birth certificates are Vital
Records they're historical documents
that contain the facts
um that were present at the time of a
person's
birth the time date parents' names and
location do not change because they're
historical facts about the birth the sex
of the baby is recorded based upon
physical
attributes identifying as a different
gender later in life does not change
history gender reassignment surgery does
not change history a woman who has
undergone gender reassignment surgery is
still a man was still a male when she
was born and vice Versa this bill states
that a new birth certificate with a
different sex than what's on the
original shall be created It also says
that the new birth certificate will not
be required to have a marginal note to
indicate that there has been an
alteration to the
record so the original document can't be
traced back to determine what it said
there would be no way to know looking at
it to know that one is looking at a
document that has been
altered and while I do sympathize with
those who wish to change their gender uh
to better reflect their lived experience
these are Vital Records if one wishes to
change their gender on their driver's
license or state ID they have that
ability and they only need to go to the
DMV and fill out a simple
form this bill creates a pathway to
change the sex on a birth certificate by
having a health care
professional um sign a form but there
are no stipulations on the expertise or
the education specialty education of the
healthcare professional in this in this
specific area of um gender transition
nor is there anything to say how long or
what the clinical relationship between
the patient and the professional are but
again birth certificates being Vital
Records historical documents should be
accurate only in extenuating
circumstances should they be changed
it's not appropriate to lower the bar
and make it easier for someone to change
their sex on their birth certificate
than it is for someone to change the
parent on a birth certificate in
adoption proceedings both are very
serious matters that should be
determined in the courts as they
currently are where the facts and
circumstances can all be considered and
weighed by an impartial judge before
such a change to historical documents
can be made thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
Canon
thank you Mr Speaker and fellow
colleagues at one time a birth
certificate was used as the primary form
of
identification with the Advent of state
issued driver's
licenses and government issued passports
with pictures of an individual and
inclusion of their current resident
information
the need for a birth certificate is
primarily used to prove where and when
an individual was
born such as when initially applying for
a
passport once that information is
included in a passport or driver's
license the certificate is rarely used I
can attest to that I changed where
certificate sits in a folder in my desk
and I hardly ever look at it never mind
mind share it with anybody
else to a transgender
individual their B original birth
certificate is an inaccurate
document it it doesn't include their eye
or hair color whether they're right or
left-handed or what their sexual
orientation
is but it does
include a note for the
gender of a child based on the best
knowledge of the attending
physician had at the time of birth that
knowledge doesn't consider that the
child's gender identity may not be
consistent with their physical
gender for the past 10 years New
Hampshire statute RSA 5-c colan 887
comma
V has given individuals the ability to
change the gender designation on their
birth certificate by petitioning the New
Hampshire Court for a court order
advising that such individual born in
the state of New Hampshire has had a sex
change a
documentation from The applicant's
Physician is used by the court to
validate the court order
request what you may not know is that
Vital Records Office only processes
about 20 of these documents each year
HB 264 simplifies the process by
requiring the
applicate present the doctor statement
to the city or town clerk along with
their birth certificate Amendment
request for
processing if in the future the
applicant decides they want to want
their certificate to change back they
will have to petition the court to do
so the bill does not delete the original
birth record from the New Hampshire
vital record systems nor does it delete
the hospital record this is the same
process that is currently in
place what it does
do is potentially save the life of a
transgender
person who was born in the state of New
Hampshire changing their birth CER
certificate to be
consistent with the gender they identify
as is more powerful than any
prescription medication or therapy
please vote hb24 264 ought to pass thank
you motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill
264 a division has been requested
members take your
seats
[Music]
e
not
yet the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 264 four this is a
division vote the chair recognized
representative kushman for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh if I
know that birth certificates serve as a
historical record and they need to
remain factual and if I also know that
this bill would allow uh Doctor Who has
little to no relationship with a patient
to sign off on them to change a vital
record and if I know that these are
already handled in the courts where it's
more um it's more unbiased and can be
weighed by an impartial judge and that
that's the appropriate venue for these
changes would I now press the red
button thank
you chair recognize representative Weber
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill will
bring efficiency and consistency to a
process that's already
happening if I know that original
records will be retained so if there is
a need to look for the original record
it will be
there and if I want to affirm the
equality and identities of all of our
citizens would I press the green
button motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill 264 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote El will attend to
stay to the
vote 86 voting yay 190 voting nay the
motion fails pres ofish Mo quman moves
expedient to
legislate speaker for what reason to
member rise I move to lay the bill on
the
table that is a higher priority motion I
request a division and a division vote
is requested the motion before us is to
lay House Bill 264 on the
table this is a division
vote
second
the motion before us is to lay house
pill 264 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to state of the
vote under 185 voting aay 191 voting a
the motion to table fails we're back to
the motion of inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the
question
all the division has been
requested I would assume everybody's
still in your
seats so we'll go right on to the vote
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 264 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
state of the
vote 191 voting yay 185 voting nay the
motion of inexpedient to legislate
passes
committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred House Bill 368 FN relative
to protections related to receiving
gender affirming healthare or gender
affirming mental health care this comes
without recommendation sen of can moves
ought to pass the chair recognizes
representative
Missour thank you Mr
Speaker this bill provides protections
for persons including adolescents
receiving gender affirming Health Care
such as gender reassignment surgery
puberty blockers
Etc let's stop there for a
second we are talking about
irreversible transition
procedures on
children in committee we were told
repeatedly by providers and other
lobbyists to quote don't worry these
procedures on children aren't happening
in New Hampshire in executive session
specic spe specific areas on both the
Dartmouth Hitchcock and Elliot Hospital
websites were referenced where it says
quote we offer a wide variety of
services for every stage of your journey
including gender affirming hormone
therapy for adults and adolescents
gender affirming surgery including Top
surgery bottom surgery and facial
feminization surgery so which is it does
New Hampshire offer this or not not
shouldn't we have a definite answer to
this question before passing a bill that
provides protections for procedures
apparently not even happening here yet
and if it is happening a lot more
research should be done as to the Future
ramifications and permanent harm that
will come as a result of this I have
heard story after Story and personally
know people who are now adults who had
irreversible transition Serv surgery
when they were younger and now have
severe health issues and struggles and
there is no going back for
them they are now permanently sterile as
well I anticipate more stories to come
just like these during subcommittee
meetings for this bill concerns arose
over the
unconstitutionality of it specifically
referencing article 4 section two of the
Constitution the subcommitte comme
initially voted 3 to one to send this
bill to interim study for more work to
be done on it we don't think making laws
that would stop another state from
enforcing their own which this bill
would do is a good
idea there are many other complex legal
issues that will arise if this bill is
passed that haven't been investigated at
all for example consider if parents in
another state are in the middle of a
custody court case and one parent
decides to take the child to another
state like ours for transition surgery
if this bill
passes if either one of the parents ends
up suing our state to gain access to
their child's medical information then
this bill would PL place in statute that
they have no right to get any of
that passing hb36 68 at this time would
undermine parental rights and set off a
chain of legal nightmares because of the
Constitutional problems embedded in the
bill as written this bill would prohibit
obtaining a subpoena of a Minor's
medical records and make New Hampshire a
sanctuary state for gender
transitions for
children between the questions we still
need currently answered from New
Hampshire's medical providers the
unconstitutionality of this bill and the
Myriad of legal issues this bill will
present if passed I urge you to press
the red button so that that work can be
done Mr Speaker I'm requesting a
division vote thank you J recognize
representative
Ken
thank you Mr
Speaker fellow
colleagues you suspect that your child
is expressing cross-gender Tendencies
and is suffering from a gender dysphoric
condition you ask the Physicians who are
working with you and their therapists
who help determine this diagnosis to
help you and your child
and they decline to help because the
state where you live in has made it
illegal for them to help you and your
child doing so would be considered child
AB abuse and the state could potentially
take your child away so you search the
internet looking for a state and medical
professionals to help you provide the
care for your child so what medical
services are they really looking
for the world professional association
for transgender health or commonly
referred to as
wpath has defined the standards of care
for transgender people young and old and
they've been updating these standards
for the past 40
years as new knowledge and medical
techniques are
introduced they adjust the
recommendations they
make
for people under the age of 18 the first
thing that is provided is therapeutic
counseling and Psychotherapy
sessions these medic these medical
professionals help the child express
what they are thinking about as far as
their gender is concerned this allows
them to determine if the child is
actually experiencing gender dysphoria
symptoms or if they are just in need of
counseling if it's determined that the
child is gender dysphoric a care plan is
developed that may include the use of
hormone blockers in ongoing
therapy hormone blockers can only be
issued under the care of an
endrocrinologist or knowledgeable
physician the patient's use of these
blockers will be monitored closely until
it's determined that in the future
hormone therapy should be
started the the plan may also allow the
child to start expressing themselves as
the gender they identify by wearing
clothing hairstyles makeup Etc
associated with their gender as well as
the use of gender appropriate name for
many young people and adults this is as
far as they
go contrary to what was shared with you
in the by the previous speaker hormone
therapy and surgical procedures
typically are part of a plan that's done
after the age of 18 and Beyond high
school
years the laws in other states that
people are looking to escape from um
don't
apply to people over the age of
18 New Hampshire does have many medical
professionals and Specialists who
understand how to care for children
suffering from into
dysphoria they are open to working with
any patient and family from
anywhere we even have a transgender
healthc Care Clinic in Dartmouth
Hitchcock hospital where families and
patients from the surrounding states
come for
care when I first introduced this B bill
it was intended to protect the fam
seeking care for the
children they are afraid that Medical
Care information might be shared with
the governing bodies of the state of
their residence where their actions even
from outside their state would be
considered child
abuse this bill would block the sharing
of medical treatment information if that
information could be used to prosecute
those families in other
states after bringing the bill forward
it became clear that not only will we
need to protect the families from these
states but we need to protect our own
medical professionals from prosecution
by other state authorities if they
provide transgender related health care
services that couldn't happen here could
it on November 17th 2023 the Attorney
General's Office of the State of Texas
issued a civil investigative demand to
the Seattle Children's Hospital in
Seattle Washington seeking documentation
associated with transgender care
provided to families who moved out of
the state of Texas to
Washington the state of Washington has
already passed a laot to block the
sharing information demanded by the
state of
Texas House Bill
368 will do the same thing to
protect New Hampshire health care
facilities and
staff please pass HB 368 to protect our
medical professionals
the families of these transgender
children and most importantly ensure
that parents have the right to make
decisions in the best interest of their
children thank
you representative moror has requested a
division
vote roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently
seconded it is it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote
for
the motion before us is autop pass on
House Bill 368 this is going to be a
roll call vote chair recognize
representative Missour for a
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that speaking against
the OTP motion of this bill is not an
attack on the lgbtq community but a
caution to wait until more due diligence
is done on it and if I know that legally
New Hampshire is not ready to be a
sanctuary state for
irreversible transition procedures on
children and if I know that it is
illegal for a minor to use a tanning
booth lastly if I know that this bill
has serious uncons serious
constitutional concerns and if
passed will have many future legal
repercussions for New
Hampshire would I then then press the
red button thank you chair recognize
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that due diligence has
been done for
years and if I want to protect the
rights of individuals seeking care and I
want to protect our medical
professionals and I want to protect the
rights of parents to make the best and
most appropriate choice for their own
children would I now press the green
button to pass this Bill thank you Mr
Speaker motion before us is the autop
pass motion on House Bill 368 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
stay to the
vote 186 voting yay 188 voting nay the
motion fails representative Missour
moves inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos
nay also will be in order division has
been requested to clarify the
vote members must remain in your seats
the motion before us right now is the
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 368 this is a division vote
for clar
vation if you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
lonte all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 190 voting yay 185 voting aay the
motion of itl
passes
committee on Health and Human Services
elderly Affairs to which was referred
House Bill 619 FN proh prohibiting
gender transition procedures for minors
relative to sex and gender and public
schools in relative to the definition of
conversion
therapy pres of Layon moves ought to
pass and offers Amendment
the debate will be on the
amendment chair recognizes
representative
wheeler I would just like to remind
anybody that is speaking on this that
this is a very
sensitive and touchy issue and please
make sure your remarks are appropriate
representative
wheeler thank you Mr Mr
Speaker and thank you for that
reminder I rise today despite the
uncomfortability of this vote because
for me it comes down to whether or not
kids should be able to get these
surgeries and despite the fact that I am
a liberal despite the fact that I
believe in non-discrimination for Trans
people for gay people for queer people
and that I will fight until my very last
day until they are recognized as human
beings the question before us is whether
or not children under the age of 18
should be able to get these
surgeries and I despite being a liberal
who believes in those human rights do
not think that is the case and when the
question is put before me and I spoke to
people until 11:30 last night lobbyists
different stakeholders people with
firsthand experience lived experience
experience and I've been speaking to
people for the last 4 weeks about this
bill the the only argument against it
being that this opens the the amendment
specifically opens the door to other bad
trans bills but folks the slippery slope
fallacy I don't think applies here we're
talking about whether or not kids should
get these surgeries and they should not
these are irreversible surgeries and
despite the fact that there are medical
exceptions which are included in this
amendment
when people have problems with their
genitals that need to be addressed that
that should be addressed but but when
we're talking about whether or not kids
should get these surgeries I think that
goes a bridge too far and I I I will not
be signing on to that so I will be
supporting this amendment and I
appreciate the work done in the Health
and Human Services committee they worked
very diligently and if you want to watch
legislating being done in real time in a
really good way I would recommend that
you watch watch the committee hearings
on this bill the work session on this
legislation because they diligently took
all people into account they took all
experiences into account and they came
up with a legislation that protects
children under the age of 18 this is not
a question of whether or not you're with
the Trans Community this is a question
on whether or not you believe children
should be able to get these irreversible
surgeries so again despite being a
Democrat despite being a liberal who
believes in human rights I don't think
that children should be able to get
these irreversible surgeries so I'll
take all the heat that comes from this I
will be voting for this amendment and
for otpa if it passes the bill in its
original form I think is too broad and I
won't be voting for OTP but I will be
voting for otpa if the bill passes and
for the amendment if it passes and I
hope all of you on this side of the
aisle who definitely believe in human
human rights who believe in protecting
non-discrimination would consider the
irreversible surgeries that kids are
going to be getting if this bill does
not pass thank you very much Mr Speaker
and I urge you to join me in supporting
this amendment J recogniz representative
Canon house will be an
order the chair recognize representative
Canon
thank you Mr Speaker fellow
colleagues the
question that we raise is not about
surgery it's not about who this applies
to it's about why are we considering
putting medical procedures into medical
into New Hampshire
law medical science is constantly
changing new procedures drugs and
treatments are introduced all the time
the medical community is constantly
learning new ways to care for
patients medical professionals are
expected to attend conferences and even
spend time learning new techniques in in
in institutions other than their own
that's their job so what is our
job our job is to protect the people we
serve statutes are written to protect us
now and long term into the
future when we consider consider putting
legislation into law we should be asking
ourselves will this legislation stand
the test of
time the problem with this
amendment is that it's a Band-Aid it's
not something this legislature is
capable of monitoring or changing as
Medical Science continues to
change if we had heard testimony with
this amendment I mean with a about
consistent problem with medical services
offered to New Hampshire residents by
new New Hampshire Medical Care
organizations and professionals it might
be a different problem for us to address
but this is not the
case we have many excellent care
providers in New Hampshire providing
their services us utilizing the best
knowledge skills and tools available to
them could they do better sure but
that's their job not
ours by the
way any youth reaching the age of 18
typically won't be approved for genital
surgery until they've started hormone
treatments for the gender they identify
as as well as Implement their future
plans as uh living as the gender they
are young people are encouraged to wait
until the age of 18 to start
them their medical professionals and
parents need to sign off on the use of
these powerful drugs any earlier than
18 Insurance approvals may also play a
part in this their
decisions they also need to start living
their life as the gender they
identify for at least a year or more
during this time they will attend many
therapeutic counseling and Psychotherapy
sessions to prove to a licensed Medical
Professional that they are capable of
living their life
safely without considering harm to
themselves or to others this is no small
task given the social pressures they
will have to live through it is much
more likely that a young transgender
person won't receive genital surgery
until they reach the age of 20 or
older also a
major part that we haven't even discuss
it that controls when these might happen
are the cost of the surgical procedures
and the willingness of surgeons and
hospitals to take the risks associated
with these proced
procedures a personal note I had to
submit letters from my therapist and
Psych therapist indicating that I was
ready for this next step even at the age
of
[Music]
69 I'm 71
now each of the three surgeons that
interviewed me wanted to make
sure that I knew what the procedure was
and what it would
entail so that they were comfortable
that I was ready same thing is true with
everyone even even 18 years
olds the insurance company also needed
to make sure that I had the right
letters in place so they they would
agree to their portion of the
bill my surgery cost over
$95,000 it wasn't a complex or expensive
female to male
procedure which the cost is cons
considerably
higher Amendment 2451 H it's a temporary
solution to a problem this legislature
can't solve in the long
term vote no on the amendment to 25 to
2023 24
51h thank you you recognizes
representative
Lon
thank you Mr Speaker I want to start off
by thanking my colleague from
summersworth for how hard and
passionately she fights for this
issue I would say that it's been
challenging to debate this with somebody
that you like and respect so much but it
makes sure that we keep things to the
issues if the medical societies and
guidelines were still practicing the way
that they have up until 16 months ago we
wouldn't be having this discussion it
used to be that a minor would need to
wait until they were 18 for
surgery it used to be in the W path
guidelines that parental consent was
required for treatment and it also used
to be in the W path guidelines that you
needed to have hormonal treatment before
surgery sadly in September 20 September
of 2022 that changed none of those
protections are no are in guidelines
anymore
so this amendment significantly Narrows
the bill it lays out the reasons why a
person should turn 18 before having
genital gender reassignment surgery if
you turn to page 93 in your calendar
you'll find the amendment which
explicitly protects reconstruction and
removal due to malformation malignancy
injury or physical disease surgeries for
disorders of sexual development and male
circumcision
this amendment laser focuses the bill on
the fact that informed
consent requires an understanding of the
risks and benefits of the
procedure if a parent is told that this
procedure is safe and effective will
they believe the doctor and sign on or
will they ask for that
evidence in committee the experts told
us that was safe and effective but they
could not give us the evidence they gave
us data on other procedur procures that
were in the underlying bill but nothing
on genital gender reassignment
surgeries I looked at PubMed where all
the clinical trials are published to see
why there is not a single study on
children having genital gender
reassignment surgery anywhere in the
world without data we're experimenting
on our children while telling their
parents that it's safe and effective I
just can't square that Circle
so the question you all face here today
is very
important is it okay to tell parents
that this surgery is safe and effective
in
children even though there are no data
and you would be leading them to have
their child unknowingly participate in
cuttingedge
surgery kids are not small adults and
children who have undergone aggressive
hormone therapy from a young age which
is what would would be needed to have
done undergone Crest sex hormones for a
while before the age of 18 have a very
very different medical history than
adults who have undergone this procedure
it's apples and oranges it's not the
same
thing our Amendment language actually
highlights the current lack of data
specifically so that if there are
published data that show that this is
safe and effective in children you will
have the wind at your backs to change
the law but we need that data first
otherwise we're misleading
parents should we tell parents it's well
studied when it's
not or should we put this pause into law
and say wait until
18 if you agree with me that we need to
wait until 18 at least until the data is
available please press the green button
for ought to pass as on this amendment
and Mr Speaker I asked for a roll call
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Amendment
2451 representative Lon has asked for a
representative Lon has asked for a roll
call vote is that sufficiently seconded
it is efficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your
seats
wor
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Amendment 2451 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
Hines for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment goes against parental rights
and goes against medical Freedom
particularly where patients should be
able to decide um whether they get that
treatment and which could prevent their
suicide which is also irreversible even
if that treatment's experimental like
many of us might have wanted to try
during early stages of covid some
experimental
treatment and if I agree with the prior
speaker yesterday we should not
substitute the government for parents
would I press red to vote against this
anti-liberty Bill thank
you chair recognize representative Lon
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that until 16 months ago no clinical
guidelines even permitted genital gender
reassignment surgery in minors anywhere
in the world and if I know that the
experts told us and parents that this
was safe and effective yet they were
unable to provide data because there are
no
data and if I know that informed consent
requires knowledge and understanding of
the risks and benefits which are in
truth unknown yet presented differently
to
parents and if I know that until
recently these kids were already waiting
until 18 for this life changing
hopefully for the the good but
potentially for the bad surgery would I
then press the green button to continue
to First Do no harm and wait until
18 motion before us is a to pass on
Amendment 2451 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 29 voting yay 167 voting nay
committee amendment is adopted now we're
on to autop pass as
amended chair recogniz your
representative
Canon
thank you Mr Speaker fellow
colleagues adopting this
bill is different than anything else
that we've done in this
house it's going to be a statute that
needs to be continually monitored for
changes by the medical
field that's that's pretty hard to do
when what we it was put laws in
place with this
current group of August
[Music]
individuals because the
future this body is going to have to
revisit this as changes are made in the
medical
field we may also have to visit other
areas too because there are changes of
who can get what surgeries and how young
and so we may need to revisit that area
as well it isn't just genital surgery
that young people
get so I encourage
you devote
no on this
bill it's not right for New
Hampshire it's not right for the
transgender
community
and I hope that our young people don't
take this message badly because I'm
concerned about the health of many young
transgender people thank
you chair recognize representative L
on thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representatives for passing this
amendment to this bill as I highlighted
before until 16 months ago these
procedures were prohibited by guidelines
so not only are there no data there are
no
anecdotes we have not yet seen how the
new W path guidelines will trickle down
into practice of medicine especially
here in New Hampshire traditionally it
takes years sometimes decades for new
guidelines to see clinical adoption
especially for surgical procedures if
that's the case here this pause does no
harm
however the natural course of
transgender Health Care has taken a very
different path than other Medical
Specialties instead of slowly and
cautiously adopting
guidelines the great desire to do
something anything to help these kids
has overwhelmed the medical mindset of
slow and cautious
adoption I appreciate the concern and
commiserate with these kids and their
families it's hard nobody denies
that but being told something is safe
and effective when there's no data and
they're just trying to figure out how it
works on you is not compassionate it's
not kind we need to wait we need to
pause and earlier this morning on the
first bill we debated we heard from my
friends on the other side of the aisle
how we could revisit that bill in the
future should the data change
our job is continually looking at the
rsas and continually updating them as
necessary it's no additional burden to
do this and to wait and see do these
help or do these harm until then I ask
you to again join with me in pressing
the green button to pass this bill as
amended so we can wait for data and wait
for until 18 thank
you and I request a roll call vote Mr
Speaker request a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members take your
seats
clear the motion be the motion before us
is a to pass as
amended on House Bill 619 this is a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that medical knowledge
evolves and with that Evolution comes
changing
guidelines happens all the
time and if I know that there will be no
data to
review if there is a specific
prohibition put in
place by all of us non medical
people and if I trust parents and
medical
providers to provide appropriate
evidence-based care would I now press
red to defeat this bill so another
motion may be made thank
you chair recognize representative Lon
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that telling parents kids and
the whole community that a procedure
with no data is safe and effective is
negligent harmful and could cost
children their lives or their future
capacity and if I know that we adapt our
laws all the time and this issue is not
going
away if I know all of that would I press
the green button so we can wait until 18
wait for data and stop misleading the
public and our kids thank
you motion before us is aut to pass as
amended on House Bill
619 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote household attend to stay to the
vote
199 voting a 175 voting a committee
report of Auto passes amended is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
place this debate in the permanent
Journal
please without objection without
objection
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 283 enact to limit
application fees charged to prospective
residential tenants having considered
the
same before everybody gets out we've got
three or four bills that aren't going to
have a debates two bills that aren't
going to have debates so can you please
remain in your
seats consider the same report the same
with the following Amendment the
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Caitlyn katab for the
committee the amendment is 2441 H
printed in house record 49 page 60 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppos nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the bill before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I those oppos nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted
we
the committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 314 FN act relative
to expectation of privacy in the
collection and use of personal
information consider the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
recommendation that bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Bob Lynn for the
committee the amendment is 2463 printed
in house record 49 Pages 63 to 64 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those nay the eyes have it and committee
amendment is adopted representative Reed
offers floor Amendment
0039 H and is recognized to speak to her
Amendment it's in your seat
Pockets thank you Mr Speaker um the
amendment before you I apologize for
having to have an emergency floor
amendment made I am in support of the
bill and I voted for similar bills all
along um this amendment adds six words
when specifically authorized by other
law this is an exemption to the rest of
it there's a similar exemption in the
first part of the bill not in the second
part of the bill I only became aware of
this because I am the chair of my Town's
energy and environment committee and we
are a founding member of the community
the community power Coalition of New
Hampshire
and late on Friday um the community
power Coalition of New Hampshire told me
that there was a a problem in 314 that
could potentially mean that cpcn would
not be able to operate so um this
amendment has as co-sponsors along with
me the Bill's Prime sponsor as well as
the committee chair and the ranking
member of the committee who authored the
original committee Amendment so um if
you agree with me that we shouldn't
accidentally
prevent uh organ or organizations and
programs that we've already authorized
by law from operating then please vote
for the amendment thank
you moot the motion before us is the
representative Reed floor Amendment 0039
H are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I I oppose nay the
eyes have it and the floor amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those favor
say I I those oppose nay the eyes have
it and the committee report is
adopted
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 396 relative to
State recognition of biological sex
comes to us without
recommendation representative Perez
moves ought to pass and offers Amendment
0441 H printed and house record 49 page
72 debate is on the floor right J we are
going to have a debate on the amendment
chair recognize representative
Divine Divine representative
divine
representative Divine the chair
recognized representative
Divine Mr Speaker I Rise to oppose House
Bill
396 the Judiciary Committee this this is
the amendment the amendment yes we're on
right now yep as amended
yep no this this is the amendment we're
we're
debating that's speaking
okay the Judiciary Committee thoroughly
examined this bill as amended proposes
to classify
individuals based solely on biological
sex a term only recently used in
legislation across the country to
justify the exclusion of transgender
individuals from sports teams restrooms
and other
settings this bill extending to both
public and private entities introduces
exceptions to New Hampshire civil rights
Provisions it narrowly defines
biological sex as male or female
overlooking
interex and transgender people and the
conflicts inherit in various sex
definitions for clarity intersex
individuals possess chromosomal gonadal
and anatomical character eristics that
do not conform to traditional binary
definitions likewise transgender
individuals often modify their birth sex
characteristics yet this bill fails to
clarify their classification leaving
them vulnerable to discriminatory
treatment this lack of clear definition
poses significant privacy
violations New Hampshire's own Sarah
Rose huckman faced obstacles in sports
participation until legislative changes
protected transgender athletes rights
such situations underscore the need for
objective respectful decision-making in
sports free from invasive personal
information
disclosures the granite state should not
undo the good work it is done to protect
all of our
citizens in this context it's crucial to
revisit our state recent our state's
recent legislative history just 5 years
ago in 2018 under a republican Le
legislature and Governor cunu New
Hampshire made a significant stride
forward in passing an
anti-discrimination law specifically
outlining and protecting gender identity
House Bill 1319 e exemplifies our
commitment to fairness and inclusivity
by contrast this amendment to House Bill
3 396 with its discriminatory stance on
biological sex seems to be a step back
from these
values this bill not only risked
undermining the protections established
for gender identity but also potentially
conflicts with federal laws like title s
of the Civil Rights Act and Title Nine
both of which Safeguard against
sex-based
discrimination bottom line this
amendment to House Bill 396 by allowing
subjective determinations of biological
sex risks violating protections for
gender diverse individuals and fostering
discrimination as lawmakers we must
prioritize our laws that respect the
dignity and rights of all people
ensuring
inclusivity and fairness in line with
the values of our state and oppose
segregation
I ask you
kindly to put House Bill 396 as amended
and in any which way it comes to rest
today thank
you chair recognizes representative
Lynn thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise in support of this amendment uh
this amendment will amend the Human
Rights Act RSA 35 54a to add a new
section
354a colon 25A the new section will
permit but not require classifications
based upon biological sex in three
narrowly tailored and specifically
defined
circumstances first in the construction
maintenance operation and use of
labatory facilities designed for usage
by multiple persons at the same time
second in athletic or sporting events or
competitions in a sport or similar
activity in which physical strength
speed or endurance is generally
recognized to give an advantage to males
and third in the operation maintenance
and use of Prisons Juvenile Detention
facilities mental health hospitals and
like facilities where people may be
committed
involuntarily the amendment provides
that in the above three
circumstances and in those circumstances
only there is a compelling State
interest in allowing classifications
based on biological sex in order to
protect the Privacy rights and physical
safety of both transgender persons and
others that may be affected by the
classification in this regard I have to
disagree respectfully with with the
prior speaker on the question of whether
there is some this is somehow an
improper classification and I would ask
you to note that unlike racial
classifications which are virtually
always almost virtually always
prohibited when dealing with
classifications based upon sex the
doctrine of separate but equal still can
be validly
utilized if that were not the case title
nine of the federal uh Title 9 of the
Education Act would be
unconstitutional because it pro it
specifically provides that that the that
the way in which equality may be
guaranteed for example in sports is not
that women must be allowed to play on
the UNH football team but that there
needs to be equivalent equal
opportunities uh for women in in in
other sports and for example if if that
if you couldn't draw racial uh sexual
classifications in these kind of cases
there couldn't be a woman's uh UNH
basketball team and a men's UNH
basketball team but in fact there are
and in fact title specifically allows
that because it recognizes that there
are some circumstances in which it is
valid to classify on the basis of
sex the three circumstances covered by
this bill are ones when a public body
such as a school district or a private
company should be able to protect the
Privacy rights of both men and women by
not allowing the mixes of the Sexes
during the inherently private activity
of using a laboratory when intimately
intimate body parts may be exposed
similarly in uh athletic organizations
should have the ability to determine
that it is inherently unfair to allow a
trans transgender male to compete
against females in sports such as
wrestling basketball tennis and other
sports where strength speed or endurance
matters lastly the special security
concerns applicable to Correctional type
facilities make it imperative that
classifications based on biological sex
be allowed in indeed with respect to the
latter situations uh Correctional
Facilities I should note here that this
is one of the very few situations where
courts have recognized that even racial
classifications may be allowed and it
happens in for example in circumstances
where there where there are white or
black gangs in a particular facil a
particular Correctional Facility courts
have upheld the ability to to classify
to to segregate uh Prisoners based upon
their race if they if in fact that's
necessary to protect you know phys
protect against physical
violence for these reasons I urge you to
support this amend this narrow amendment
to this bill which makes common sense
and would be good public policy and Mr
Speaker I asked for a division vote
thank
you does the member yield the
questions does does a member yield the
questions member does not
yield
the motion before us is amendment 044 h
a division has been
requested who request a roll
call Roll King is requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your
seats
clear
the motion before us is the roll call
vote on Amendment
04418 chair recognizes representative
Tura for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that I
don't know what the term biological sex
in this amended bill or Amendment to the
bill means or how it would be determined
or applied and if I further know that
nobody here knows what it means because
it's not defined in this bill or
Amendment or anywhere else in New
Hampshire statute and if if I further
know that there are at least four
commonly used biological based
approaches to defining one sex Each of
which objectively embodies more than the
two sex classifications called for in
the amended Bill and that any of these
can classify the same individual in
opposite ways at a single point in their
life or different points in one's
life and if I know that these concerns
are not just theoretical hyperbole but
that such policy has been used for
example to force a transgender male to
compete in wrestling as a female based
on birth sex in Texas where he
ironically became the state's undefeated
girl state champion in 2017 and 2018
against his will and lastly if I know
that the deeply personal information
needed to make any of these
classifications
correctly is not typically revealed or
documented publicly and should not be
wouldn't I then necessarily conclude
that if enacted this statute could only
be applied in an invasive and arbitrary
way which could justify completely
opposite policy in the same situation
literally opening the door to the very
discrimination that the Republican Le
legislature and governor
cunu passed remind the member this is a
parliamentary inquiry not a speech yeah
passed a specific law to prevent just 5
years ago isn't this more than
sufficient reason to press the red
button to uphold the protections of
individual rights personal privacy and
basic human dignity that our state has
already chosen to embrace on a
bipartisan basis thank you Mr Speaker J
recognize representative kall for a
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill clarifies the
law that it it offers uh
protections to all New Hampshire
citizens in three narrowly defined areas
intimate spaces athletic competitions
and prisons furthermore Mr Speaker if I
know that the 11th circuit court has
already affirmed that a school's
decision to distinguish bathroom and
locker rooms based on biological secks
has been ruled
constitutional would I then press the
green button to pass this amendment so
that we can move forward with an
otpa motion on the bill thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is ought to
pass on Amendment
4418 it's a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you press a red button
voting station are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
while members presid had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 194 voting a 182 voting nay the
amendment is adopted
we
for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker would it be possible for
me to ask a question um of someone from
the committee in who supports the bill
as
amended if one of the
members yes one of the members Will
consent
chair will answer your question thank
you there was still a debate on the bill
this is this is on the bill right as
amended have I'm sorry I can't hear you
we we still have a debate on the bill
itself as
amended yes thank you
um thank you so much Mr chairman for
being willing to take my question
because I hold you in high regard could
you define for me um biological
sex yeah I believe I I I I believe that
biological sex ba I mean basically going
back to my sort of uh high school
biology basically means that if you have
the XX chromosome you're a woman if you
have the XY you're a man and I'm not
aware although I'm certainly not a
scientist that there has been any um any
uh any change to that basic uh that
basic uh classification h house will be
in
order than thank you may I follow up
thank you so much for that and thank you
for
it the house will be in order and thank
you for ignoring the um inappropriate
response from our colleagues um can you
tell me where in law since you more than
anyone in this room could answer this
question wherein law that is defined
thank you I I I I suspect he probably
not and you know the but the the if the
question is that because it's not
defined we can't we can't decide who is
a male and who is a female biologically
I have to say respectfully you know that
has that has been
deciding uh on on who is a male or who
is not and in classifications dealing
with that has been something that courts
and frankly the public has been doing
for centuries so the idea that somehow
you know we now can't do that I
respectfully I disagree it's just it's I
think it's very easy to make that
determination thank
you will a member yield to a further
question member does not yield member
does not yield we still have a debate on
the bill build the motion before us now
is ought to pass as amended chair
recognize representative
Tura thank you Mr Speaker um I Rise
Again in opposition to passing the
amended bill um many of the reasons were
stated
previously um on the uh discussion of
the amendment uh to Echo the discussion
you just
heard the lack of a definition in this
bill or anywhere in New Hampshire
statute and I did search for it um means
that the term biological sex can be
applied however somebody wishes to do
it and the case that I mentioned in
Texas um where it was applied based on
birth uh sex at Birth was a specific
example of the most commonly accepted
version of biological sex that it's
established at Birth if we adopt a
definition where someone can do that we
are opening the door to the same
situation here where we could tell
somebody who is uh outwardly a male who
has male musculature
and male characteristics to be to play
on women's teams we could be telling
someone who is transitioned and has you
know a beard and male musculature maybe
even male Galia that they have to use
the woman's room because that's how they
were born that is why this bill is
dangerous this bill leaves the door wide
open for anyone in the state to
basically undo as I said the bipartisan
agreement to protect people in these
situations from the Discrimination it
was said that this doesn't require this
application but allows it I'll say it
doesn't require discrimination but it
certainly allows discrimination and I
think we should really pause before we
adopt something that can be applied in
any way that someone sees fit literally
opposite ways by two organizations right
next door to each other
that is the reason why and and I will
just finally end with the fact that um
uh with respect to Chairman Linn's
answer to the question that was posed if
we go by chromosomes as I mentioned
there are about four different ways that
this is most likely done chromosomes is
one of the four when you when you look
at biology there are there's a condition
called kleinfelter syndrome which is an
xxy
chromosome um so that definition will
not hope there's also an XO um
chromosomal uh situation and both of
these people can can can live in society
but will not be easily classified and so
I think we should step back from what uh
this bill would would suggest that we do
thank you Mr Speaker does remember yield
a
questions does does the member yield the
questions oh no thank no member does not
yield member does not yield
J recognize representative
kofalt J recognize representative
Lynn thank you Mr Speaker uh uh
colleagues I I will not belabor uh
because I've I think I've said most of
what I needed to say before but let me
just let me just raise one thing to ask
you to think about on this whole issue
of like whether or not we really can't
tell we can't make a classification
about whether somebody is a male or
female stop and think about that just
for a minute suppose that we really were
to say that was true wouldn't that mean
that in that in
protecting uh females for example in the
in as as it as the uh
anti-discrimination laws apply generally
just stop and think about that situation
if you were really to accept the idea we
can't tell who's a male or who's a
female suppose that UNH had a male had a
had a basketball team just one
basketball team and all of the people on
it sort of looked like males and acted
like males and and was they were playing
other male teams and they had no female
basketball team and somebody came along
and said hey wait a minute you're
discriminating this male basketball team
you're discriminating could could they
say oh hold on wait a minute we don't
how do you how do you know that we're
males how do you know you can't tell we
have you know what on What basis are you
making this kind of decision
I would respectfully submit to you that
if that kind of an argument was made a
court would laugh it out of court I mean
it's of course you can make these
decisions uh and that and you can make
it here also these are three narrow
circumstances in which classification
based upon biological sex makes sense
for privacy protection and safety
reasons I urge you to support the Bill
otpa thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass unamended on House Bill 396
representative Lynn has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
clear
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
396 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Divine for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I understand that house bill
396 as amended is turned into a he said
said she said issue like it has here on
the floor
today and if I know the classification
of human beings based solely on
biological sex in this bill is as
impractical as trying to classify a fish
in the ocean as a bird in the sky
particularly in a state that values the
principles of Live Free or
Die then would I wouldn't I wouldn't it
be logical and in keeping with our
state's values of inclusivity fairness
and respect for individual identity
press the red button to
declare House Bill
396 inexpedient to
legislate thank you Mr Speaker and if it
comes down to it I'd appreciate your
vote very
good chair chair recognized
representative kall for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I understand that house bill 396 as
amended clarifies the law provides
important clarifications for uh school
districts prisons and other subdivisions
of the state would I then press the
green button thank you Mr Speaker motion
before us is aut to passes amended in
House Bill 396 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote househ will attend to state of
the
vote 192 voting a 184 voting a committee
report is
adopted
e
the majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which was referred House
Bill 652 FN an act relative to
non-public sessions under the right of
no law having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate Representative Bob ly for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
Christine Perez for the minority of the
committee the minority committee
amendment is 2438 H prined in house
record 49 on pages 107 and
108 representative Hull is recognized to
speak for the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker I speak here
um as someone who helped author the pink
sheet and there's a typo that you can
attribute to me where I substituted the
word oppose for support so I'm just
letting all the members know who would
have looked at the pink sheet on this
bill that there is an error we're
supporting the itl thank
you representative Perez is recognized
to speak against the
report thank you Mr speaker thank you
representative House Bill
652 is a Bill to design to help you help
you help you help all of
us 91a laws were passed to give the
public your
constituents transparency in
government but they don't include
non-public
sessions House Bill 652 will give you
the right to attend a nonpublic public
session member will suspend for a minute
please pause sorry about that please
continue we ready I'll good
okay so I rise in opposition to the
itl house bill 652 will you give you the
right to attend a non on public session
if you are being discussed and your
reputation could be as versely
affected it protects you from possible
false accusations made against you in
non-public
session perhaps an accusation made by a
public official who just doesn't like
the can of worms you may have opened and
potentially corruption in the town
now if the accusation against you is a
crime that needs to go directly to law
enforcement they are not subject to 91a
and they will do their own
investigation I know that due process
might be way your way to reclaim your
reputation or an attempt to write the
wrongs done to you but that may be just
too late the damage has already been
done to you not everyone also has the
means to hire a lawyer or the time to
devote to the long legal
process especially since nothing nothing
might have happened if you had just had
the
opportunity to speak to the allegations
made against you in the first place
House Bill 652 will allow this process
and perhaps the entire issue could have
been cleared with a meeting with no cost
to any
party now you may need not think that
this is happening but I can assure you
that it is and it's coming to your
neighborhood it has come to Dairy it has
come to pelum it has come to others so
let's nip this in the
bud if you believe that you have the
right to hear what is being said about
you behind closed
doors and you have the right to speak on
your own behalf this is the bill that
will provide that for
you House Bill 652 will protect the
rights and reputation of your
constituents the average citizen before
they are adversely affected I Ur urge
you to vote to pass this bill and to
vote against the itl thank
you representative Lynn is recognized to
speak for the committee
report thank you thank you Mr Speaker um
I rise in opposition uh and in support
of the uh as opposition to the prior
speaker and in support of the itl motion
for this bill the right to no law
currently allows public bodies to go
into non-public sessions to discuss
matters which may reflect adversely on
anyone other than a member of the public
body the original Bill proposed to amend
this proi this provision to say that
before the public body can rely on this
section to go into non-public session it
must give the person who may be spoken
about uh adversely 48 Hours advanced
notice the right to be present at the
meeting to have Council or a
representative present and to speak in
his or her own
behalf the problem with this bill is
that there are very often good reasons
why a public body may need to have a
conf confidential discussion without
notifying the person is to be discussed
adversely that such discussions are to
occur the most obvious example of this
is where a member of a public body
receives information suggesting that
someone may have engaged in wrongdoing
what could be could be criminal could be
civil but could be some kind of
wrongdoing and needs to discuss with the
body how to proceed whether to involve
the police or some
regulatory um Authority uh to launch an
investigation Etc if the body were
required to give notice to the potential
wrongdoer in such situations the result
could easily be to frustrate the
investigation by tipping uh the hand to
the wrongdoer in you know much too
early supporters of this bill recognized
the problem that I just discussed and
sought to fix it by a proposed amendment
by a proposed amendment which would say
that notice must be given only prior to
the public body taking a vote or taking
action regarding the person in question
the amendment also
also uh would would propos listed a
number of exceptions to it dealing with
certain regulatory
bodies
um I have to say that although the
amendment improves the bill slightly it
by by no means fix fixed all of the
problems for example even under the
proposed amendment if the public body
were to take a vote to refer a uh uh
matter of potential wrongdoing to the
police or the AG for investigation the
amendment would require that the alleged
wrongdoer be tipped off that of that
that action was being done again there
would be grave potential for uh for
frustrating
investigations the other point the other
problem with this with this bill is that
the proposed amendment to the bill was
made at the last minute without without
adequate opportunity for full discussion
of the implica potential implications of
this so that for example this am the the
the the proposal as as suggested by the
prior speaker as reflected in proposed
amendment is really much more than a
right to know Bill it it it in effect is
a sort of due process bill it is
designed to give people who maybe some
adverse action may be taken against
notice and an opportunity to be heard on
a on a at a you know at a very 50,000
foot level that sounds like a good idea
in fact and I can I could support that
in fact in another context I have a bill
coming up in uh before the new session
of the legislature dealing with dealing
with due process rights in educational
in the educational setting so I'm a
strong supporter of due process rights
the problem is that this bill has and
the proposed changes that arguably could
have some Merit
have not been thought out we we haven't
had any hearings on which people have
said well look if you if you if you
proceed in the way the proponents of the
amendment have said here are some of the
problems we may have we don't know what
those what those problems might be
because we haven't heard from Witnesses
dealing with with with that issue so I
guess what I'm really saying in bottom
line is I think we need to itl this bill
because it's not really ready for prime
time maybe at in some fure future legisl
legis uh legislation it may be
appropriate to to have something like
this that says you know there's a
there's a sort of statutory right to doe
process uh hearing and right to be be
notified and have and uh be heard and
have an attorney in certain
circumstances but we need to know all of
the parameters of that before we vote on
it and right now this is not where
that's not where we are so for those
reasons I urge you to support the itl
recommendation uh thank you Mr
Speaker will the member Yi to a question
will the member yield for a
question
yes thank you very much for uh yielding
to the question
um so my my question is what kind of
action it mean I support due process and
that's why at least on the surface I
like the Bild but I know I understand
the problem of authority investigation
so you know in a police investigation
for criminal thing that is private and
then if they decide to charge you then
that you have your due process and you
can respond for a body like a let's say
a board of selectman or a city council
can they take action without you having
a chance to
respond um or is it just that it's
private until they decide what they want
to do
that's no I mean I think really you
identify one of what I think is really
the the big one of the big problems with
the bill as it now is as it now is even
with the proposed amendment it doesn't
Define what action means so does is is
if let me give you this example suppose
a selectman receives information from a
constituent that somebody let's say
somebody that the city or the town is
Contracting with may have double build
or may have uh not provided U not been
doing the work that they were supposed
to do and the selectman decides I want
to I want to have a discussion with
colleagues at the next selectman's
meeting about this uh to decide what to
do should they have should that have
should the person have to be notified of
that where there might be some
wrongdoing or isn't it appropriate to be
able to have that discussion privately
first now if the if the if the board of
selectman decides well yes you know
we're going to refer this to uh uh for
some kind of further investigation and
in fact the further investigation leads
to a civil suit being filed or a
criminal of course the person has to be
has the right to be notified but this I
I think would would would require notice
too early that's my that's that's the
problem question before the house is on
the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the report is
adopted the committee on Judiciary to
which was referred Senate Bill 255 FN an
act relative to the expectation of
privacy having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative margerie Smith for the
committee the amendment is
2420 printed on house record 49 on pages
116 to 118 the question is on the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose
nay I think the eyes have it and the
Amendments adopted the question now is
on the majority committee report of a to
pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppos
nay uh sorry the eyes have
it and the report is
adopted the majority of the committee on
labor industrial and rehabilitative
services to which was referred House
Bill 190 FN an act relative to the
duration of unemployment benefits having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative William infantine for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Michael
Granger for the minority of the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I all those oppose nay the eyes have it
and the report is
adopted
without the committee on labor
industrial and Rehabilitation of
services to which is referred House Bill
232 FN adopting section 1910 OSHA
standards for public sector employees in
New Hampshire comes to us without
recommendation representative seaworth
moves out to pass offers amendment 2
49h printed in house record 49 on page
57 representative Sullivan recognized
speak against the
amendment
morning I rise in opposition to this
amendment uh to be clear this amendment
would fully replace um House Bill three
232 um as would the next amendment that
we'll be talking about um I oppose this
amendment because frankly it completely
defeats what house bill 232 was intended
to
do House Bill
232 is intended to
improve um workplace safety for public
sector
employees private sector employees as
most of us know are protected by OSHA
safety
standards um public sector employees are
covered by the New Hampshire Department
of Labor safety
standards I have to say that those New
Hampshire Department of lab labor safety
standards are woefully
incomplete the whole purpose of this
bill is to improve upon those standards
and make the safety standards for public
sector
employees more equivalent to the public
sect or the private sector um
employees this amendment was well-
intended it was trying to make something
that was highly
palatable it became so palatable that it
doesn't really do
anything um
basically it allows the Department of
Labor to uh hire three more employees
for the purpose of rul making the
department can write rules to improve
safety standards all the standards that
are there are in rules
presently the problem is the department
has
not for over a decade made any
Improvement to the um public sector
safety
standards this
amendment doesn't require any
improvements to the safety state
standards for public sector
employees department has made it clear
and I had a discussion with the um
Deputy Commissioner for the Department
of
Labor she indicated that this bill if
amended in this fashion doesn't require
them to do anything further with regard
to safety standards gives them three
more employees to write rules but
there's no incentive or requirement to
actually write those rules
so I ask you to oppose this amendment
and consider a new amendment that
actually will improve workplace safety
for public sector employees thank
you representative infant signes
recognized to speak in support of the
amendment thank you Mr Speaker OSHA
occupational s safety and health
administration enacted in April of
1971 for private
employers every private employer must
now adhere to OSHA
standards however most people don't
understand that states and
municipalities do not have to follow
OSHA they've had their own standards a
few states do follow ocean
now but a vast majority do
not the New Hampshire Department of uh
labor for years has adjudicated safe
safy they put out a manual they inspect
they investigate accidents and it's all
being done with the Department of
Labor now I am in support of doing
something here
to update where we need to be on safety
with the Department of Labor in the
state of New Hampshire it has been 10
years it is time it is time to update
where we are with
safety the other proposal
is
uh a division of Osha 1910 don't know
what it stands for it's not a date it's
just a number it's a th000 pages
long I had to get permission from the
speaker's office to print it so I could
start reading it because I wanted to
know what was in it before it passed it
so I wanted to read it I've also talked
to Department of uh Public Works in my
city ad Manchester and to paraphrase him
it's like why is a legislature meddling
in this why are you getting involved we
are not safety experts I'm OSHA 10
certified okay so I sat for 10 hours and
I got certified on safety I doesn't make
me an OSHA expert I'm an insurance agent
I spous safety on construction sites in
the manufacturing plants I'm not an
expert and none of us are it belongs
with the Department of
Labor the the uh also technology and
other things municipalities are doing
things on their own the city of
Manchester uses toter now and the
Machine picks up to take the trash it
has reduced workers comp claims by 50%
in the city of Manchester we are
utilizing these things the Department of
Labor complains a little bit about not
having enough
money they receive funding from workers
compensation policy another
things and they have an excess of over
$3 million a year in their budget that
goes to the general
fund well we we're either over taxing
people or we should utilize the money
for safety we're going to have the
argument about over taxing
later I want the Department of Labor to
go back and to do what they were doing I
don't want the legislature every four
five 10 years to establish safe
protocols that's what the department
should do so this allots a certain
amount of money for them to hire some
people and and go do what needs to be
done there are a lot of other states in
this country that have manuals I got to
believe when they go to these
conferences all over the
country that they can get other manuals
and look and see what other states who
have updated their safety manuals and
bring that to New Hampshire I think that
is the New Hampshire way that's why I
would like you to
support my Amendment it's not perfect it
doesn't tell the Department of Labor you
must do this this and this there are
supposed to be doing it it gives them
the money to do it thank you very
much the question is on Amendment
29h division's been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
e
the question is on amendment 2
49h
representative Susu is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I
believe the safety standards for public
sector workers should be updated and if
I know that HB 232 is written to require
the Department of Labor to improve these
safety
standards and I know that this amendment
does authorized three additional
full-time positions within the
Department of Labor however if I know
that this amendment does not require the
department to actually improve safy
safety standards would I now vote
against the amendment by pressing the
red button thank you Mr
Speaker representative infant signs
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
amendment appropriates the money to the
Department of Labor to be able to update
their safety than I would then would
I where I pressed the green button thank
you very
much the questions on the adoption of
amendment 2409 H this is a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
Thomas represent Wendy
Thomas have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house shall
attend to the state of the
vote 184 in the affirmative 186 and the
negative the amendment
fails
representative Sullivan moves Amendment
29h and house record 49 printed on page
58 for what reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to make a
motion of
tabling
representative chot moves at House Bill
232 be laid on the table are you ready
for the question this will be a division
vote members take your seats if you left
[Music]
them representative chart requests a
roll call which is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
clear
the question is
on whether to lay House Bill 232 on the
table representative Sullivan's
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill has been working on for three or
four years
now and if I know that it's been a
strong bipartisan effort to make this
happen and if I know
that workplace safety is something that
should be important to all of
us would I then press the red button to
defeat this tabling motion thank
you the question is whether the Lous
Bill 232 on the table and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Rich have all members presence had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 190 in the affirmative 182 and the
negative House Bill 232 was laid on the
table the committee on legislative
Administration which is referred House
Bill 301 an act relative to recusal by
members of the general court for
conflicts of interest having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
Vanessa shean for the committee for what
reason does a member rise for
motion have at it would would like to
lay hb31 on the table representative
Hill moves that house bill 301 be laid
on the table are you ready for the
question all those in FA somebody asked
for a division
all right then this will be a division
vote members should be in their
seats
members should be in their seats we're
in the voting
mode
the question is whether to L House Bill
301 on the table and this is a division
vote if you are in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
ases
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
it was a squeaker the house will attend
to the state of the
vote 359 in the affirmative 13 in the
negative house build 301's laid on the
table the house will now attend
lunchtime
announcements representatives plet and
Greg have a lunch time
announcement
okay representative Greg and I would
like you to supplement your lunch in the
cafeteria with free coffee and cookies
uh courtesy of the grenet bridge
legislative Alliance figure out what the
Gren Bridge legislative Alliance is see
if you want to be involved thank you see
you
there representative Penza has a
lunchtime announcement straford County
Republicans were having a lunch meeting
across the street at The Barley
House Representative wihm is recognized
for lunchtime announcement thank you Mr
Speaker house Democrats we're going to
stay here in caucus for about five
minutes
thanks the house will be in recess until
House Bill 313 next relative to
reductions from the default budget for
official ballot Town meetings consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legis L Jim
representative Jim magori for the
majority
minority having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment sen of Josh Okala
for minority of the committee chair
recogniz
repella thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to the current motion of itl
I been on my town budget committee
longer than I have been a state rep and
I believe that some of the most
impactful work that we can do um is to
be part of our local town and city
government I represent one town with
traditional Town meetings and two towns
with
sb2 one negative of sb2 is the reduced
power of the electorate with regard to
budgets how so in town meetings you can
adjust budgets by up to 10% which is
nominally the same as sb2 municipalities
however with sb2 municipalities the
default budget is like an anchor for
which the further you deviate up or down
from the default the more likely the
default is to be chosen by the voters
and the default is chosen by us in
conquered not the
municipality one budget Committee Member
in my town resigned because they
determined that the default
calculation is wholly undermining the
work the committee work of the budget
Committee in our town conquered has set
the default
calculation to be simple however that
Simplicity does not lend itself to
accuracy
um for uh accuracy of the actual need to
continue the services for example in my
town the administrator tried to set the
default budget for the fuel line to be
the need for the fuel to heat the town
buildings and since she knows that
inflating the numbers in the budget
makes it harder to get those budgets
passed however I informed her that
conquer doesn't allow setting up the
default budget to the actual projected
cost when there's no contract agreed by
the voters and must stay the same
request as in the default budget that
was passed the prior year
another um is well this bill does not
try to address the forecasting of fuel
cost but the common uh but a known
amount the cost of the current working
staff to provide the the government
services approved by the voters in the
prior year a cursory glance might lead
you to believe that keeping the same
amount approved by the voters the prior
year would be quite accurate however let
me give you a couple of examples imagine
you're hiring a new position and the
voters pass the maximum amount that they
would like to pay for that being
$150,000 and let's say it passes by the
voters and they all agreed to that now
if the person is actually hired in the
next month and their salary is only
$100,000 they work for the entire year
the next default budget comes up
or the next budget process comes up the
budget committee knows it's going to
cost
$100,000 the select board knows it's
going to cost
$100,000 the taxpayers know that it's
$100,000 the default budget is still the
$150,000 because conquered
CHS another example is if a long ten
tenured employee is getting paid
$150,000 retires and you hire a new
employee that is not as experienced and
they they pay is only $100,000 they've
worked they're employed in that
position everyone knows once again the
taxpayers the Selectmen everyone knows
it's going to cost $100,000 to fulfill
those needs of the community but conquer
has decided that it should be
$150,000 in the default budget so just a
few weeks ago I asked my my local school
board about why a salary
line uh in the default budget was way
higher than they were asking
for um in their proposed budget when the
school uh they responded quote the
default budget calculation is calculated
by taking last year's appropriation and
multiplying it by the contractual
increase in the CBA the difference in
the proposed budget reflects the actual
reduction in salaries and benefits due
to turnover the default cannot be
calculated using actual reductions and
costs because it's a a statutory formula
that is based on last year's
appropriation they went on to say quote
we are requesting exactly what we
need in the proposed budget the default
budget is not a budget request it's a
statutory formula and the default budget
in this case is higher because the cost
of the more expensive employees are part
of last year's appropriation which gets
carried over in the default budget
unquote as you know the passage of
Municipal Bud budgets is in large part B
based on the mutual trust between the
governing body and the
voters and when the default budget
reflects known overstatements in cost
and neither the town vote town or the
voters can do anything about it it it
erodes that
trust and so for those reasons ple I ask
you to please vote no on itl so that we
can incorporate the known costs of these
current employees into the default
budget so that the default budget May
more ACC accurately reflect the known
needs instead of an overly simplistic
one in statute now thank you Mr Speaker
a member yield the
questions sure remember yields May
inquire thank you Mr Speaker and uh
thank you representative would you
believe that in the town of Deerfield it
has been over a decade since we passed a
proposed Municipal budget and that in
that decade under default budget
there have been increases every year
that have kept pace with
inflation and we have res we have
returned a healthy operating Surplus
back to the taxpayers under default
budgets every year except for one would
you would you find that to be uh
interesting thank you for the question I
do find all your anecdotes quite
interesting thank
you J recognized representative
Harland thank you Mr
Speaker oops is that
better a transparent Municipal
budget is that better all
right okay all right uh a trans parent
Municipal budget process that engages
residents of your community uh and
clearly explains why a budget makes both
long-term and short-term sense is
essential to building the trust and
support that's needed to pass a budget
unfortunately there are times when the
local governing body and the voters are
not on the same page and the budget is
rejected and the default is adopted no
Community wants to find them elves in
this position it's incredibly
challenging the default budget allows
the municipality to continue to operate
it pays the wages or the salaries of the
employees and it meets the contractual
obligations of the community but it
strips out any one-time expenditures for
example like your vehicle replacement
program your Capital Improvement program
and potentially your road programs are
all
paused so the local governing body is
faced with trying to come up with a
budget over the next year and get the
community on board again it's a really
challenging process House Bill 313 makes
that challenging process much more
difficult by having the state step in
and limit the ability of a Lo local
municipality to solve their own problems
it it states as was already brought up
that if a employee that is hired before
the public hearing of the proposed
budget if their salary is less than the
budgeted salary the default budget would
reflect that so the example would be if
we were going to hire a public works
director and the salary was
$100,000 and the actual salary that we
uh gave to them was
$80,000 the default budget would then
reflect the $80,000
salary and the bill alleges that this
money is being used to pad the default
budget in reality every municipality has
the ability to use unexpended funds so
if you don't use your fuel it's a warm
winter and you aren't plowing or an
employee costs less than is needed all
of those unexpended funds go into the
fund balance the municipality can then
decide whether to use those funds to
drive down the tax rate or as occurs
each year when you guys H when the
municipality has an audit some of those
funds are held in reserve in case
unexpected things come up the municipal
and County government majority felt that
house bill a house bill
313 really strips municipalities the
ability to solve their own problems it
dictates how they can spend their
funds therefore we recommended that this
bill should be in expedient to
legislate we hope that Representatives
will support their local control and
follow the the recommendation of the
committee thank
you sorry division vote Mr Speaker a
division vote
please the motion before us is the
majority committee report of inex
legislator on House Bill 313 a division
has been requested members take take
your seats this will be a division
vote
the motion before us is a majority
commit report of any me to legisla on
House Bill 313 this is a division
vote
the chair recognized from C power for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill simply includes
actual salary and benefit reductions
resulting from employee turnover in the
list of Provisions in statute used to
calculate the default budget and if I
know that this will result in a default
budget that more accurately reflects the
true dollar amount needed to be raised
and appropriated through taxation
preventing unnecessary over taxation of
our constituents would I now vote no to
oppose the committee recommendation of
itl and push the red button so that a
different motion can be made thank you
Mr Speaker chair recognize
representative Gilman for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the governing
body of a political subdivision of the
state must clearly inform the public of
what and why there monetary differences
between a proposed budget and a default
budget in performing their fiduciary
duties and and if I know that every
local government has different needs at
different times than another but their
voters and residents expect their level
of service to remain and if I know the
quote commitments unquote described in
The Minority Report can hamper those
continued Services by flattening the
capability of hiring retention
recruitment due to unanticipated
retirements leaves of absence and Market
level competi ition would I then stop
this state overreach that mandates the
administration of every local government
remains static by pressing the green
button button and voting this Bill itl
thank you Mr
Speaker the watch for us is the majority
committee report of itl on House Bill
313 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your oppos you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e
[Music]
represent
Murray represent
Gilman
months
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 188 voting yay 184 voting nay
committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on resource
Recreation and development to which is
referred House Bill 194 FN an act
requiring the director of the division
of archives and Records management to
compile and maintain a list of public
monuments consider the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment sentive Rosemary
rung for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that as
inexpedient to legislate sen Rob harvy
for minority of the committee amendment
is 00 37h printed in house record 49
page 57 are you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
I I those oppose nay the eyes have it
and the amendment is
adopted chair recognizes representative
harb
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker and
fellow Representatives I rise in
opposition to HB
194 while the minority is not opposed to
keeping a record of all monuments in the
state this bill is unnecessary and
flawed basic definitions are missing
such as the definition of
monuments this can result in significant
confusion and different
interpretations testimony was received
that this bill and a list of monuments
can be collected from cities and towns
and posted on the website the director
of division of historical resources said
via email he could do it now without
additional funding the minority believes
this bill as presented to the house is
not ready for passage the minority is
supportive of the idea of this bill but
the text and content of the bill needs
work please press the red button so that
another motion might be made thank you J
recognizes represent
Gera thank you very much Mr Speaker uh
if we only had a nickel for every time
someone stood in this well and and uh
said that this is a very simple Bill uh
it's right up there with I'll be brief
uh uh but in this case I I really mean
it this is a very very simple Bill to
have the state compile and maintain a
list of all publicly maintained
monuments in the state and I want to
address a couple of the concerns that
were just raised by the previous speaker
and that were raised in committee first
of all the bill provides a precise
definition of The Monuments to be put on
this list by stating that these are
publicly maintained monuments every
municipality in the state has a list of
monuments that they maintain uh and the
uh division of historical resources
would simply ask for that list they
would receive the list and would go on
the list so uh the what constitutes a
monument is precisely defined by the
qualifying term publicly
maintained second of all with regard to
the necessity of this bill the testimony
by email that my uh esteemed colleague
just referred to uh the the director of
that division also made it crystal clear
to the committee that in order for this
to be maintained every 10 years that
requires a statutory change but I think
we can all agree with changes in
legislatures changes in directors and
other employees at agencies that it is
important if we want something to be
updated and to be maintained that we uh
make sure that we make proper provision
for that uh what my hope here with this
list as a historian uh I would love it
if anybody here who wanted to visit all
of the war memorials for example in the
state of New Hampshire you go to one
place on uh State of New Hampshire
website you can find out where all those
War memorials are and you can travel
around the state and see all of those
great sites for yourself uh and as an
educator I also see this as a valuable
tool for us to uh instill uh in our
students and our young people uh love of
place love of this great state of the
people and uh the cultures of the
Granite State so for all of those
reasons I ask you all to uh vote otpa on
this Bill thank you Mr Speaker
representative manulo has asked for a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
C the motion before us is majority
committee report of aut pass as amended
on House Bill 194 this is a roll call
vote how house will be in
order chair recognized representative
manulo for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill is
seriously flawed and has the distinct
possibility of requiring funding to make
it
viable and if I know that the director
of historical resources supports the
bill and has stated that the tasks
required could be done by him without
legislation and with no additional
funding
then we should itl the bill as it is not
needed press the red button thank
you chair recognize representative Peto
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know as a former
New Hampshire teacher of the year whose
students from meramac high school
successfully competed against students
from across the country in the National
History Day competition in Washington DC
by utilizing Prime resource
documents historical sites and monuments
that this bill will provide a tremendous
resource to all students and teachers in
in New Hampshire and if I know that it
requires no funding as a division of
historical and cultural resources
already has the Staffing to do this and
finally Mr Speaker if I know that
requiring the department to update the
list every 10 years necessitates a
change in the statute but I now press
the green button to vote Yes to adopt
this motion thank you Mr
Speaker motion before us the majority
committee report of aut pass as amended
andh house one94 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 194 voting yay 1979 voting aay
committee report is adopted and it's on
its way to
finance committee on resource Recreation
and development to which is referred
House Bill 434 FN an act relative to
flying drones in state parks consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
will Darby for the committee I are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay no the
eyes have it and the committee report is
adopted majority of the committee on
science and technology and energy to
which was referred House Bill 166 an act
relative to the elimination of useful
thermal energy from renewable energy
classes having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate sen of Doug Thomas from the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Senator Michael Harington from the
minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative
Harrington thank you Mr Speaker I
suppose I had to start out by saying
what is useful thermal energy from
having discussions with many many reps
on this I realize there's a lot of you
who have no idea what that term means
and what I'm talking about so if you
don't know think about how many you
constituents know I would guess the
number is pretty close to zero so how do
we get to useful thermal energy in the
law well back a few years ago a wood
ship manufacturer had very good lobbyist
and they were able to get a law passed
to expand the renewable portfolio
standard which deals with renewable
electric production to include furnaces
that burn wood these are large scale
industrial furnaces that use wood to
produce their heat rather than oil or
natural gas there's nothing in here that
reduces the use of electricity
whatsoever it simply reduces the use of
other forms of heating which is
basically limited to oil and natural gas
and we're talking industrial siiz
facilities here so someone puts in one
of these industrial siiz wood burning
furnaces and for every equivalent
megawatt hour of energy they produce
they get a wreck the same as a solar
producer gets a wreck who produces solar
electricity or someone who produces
electricity from wind gets a wreck now
these wrecks have to be bought by the
electric utilities again this has got
nothing to do with electric production
whatsoever but the electric utilities
have to buy these wrecks they forced by
laws to do it just like they have to buy
the wrecks that come out of solar energy
small hydro and wind power so the
electric utilities by these Recs what do
they do with them they don't eat the
cost they bury them in rates and they're
passed on to your rate payer so again if
you were to go out and ask your
constituent how many people know that my
electric bill is higher so I can afford
so someone else gets the subsidy for
large industrial wood burning boilers
and I'm going to say probably no one
unless you happen to have a constituent
that owns one of those industrial
furnaces the answer is going to be zero
so here we have a subsidy that's buried
in electric rates that has nothing to do
with electric production it doesn't
increase electric production it doesn't
reduce it it has nothing to do with
whatsoever and it's hidden it doesn't
show up on the bill this is the perfect
example of bad government we're giving
subsidies to special interest groups and
we're paying having somebody pay for it
that don't even know they're paying for
it if people think such a great idea to
stimulate the wood products industry
that we should have more wood being
harvested and give them a subsidy then
let's put it out in the open especially
members of my party who are always
standing up here saying I'm against this
tax that tax and all taxes and taxes
theft well this is a hidden tax this is
one of the worst types you can have if
you want to tax uh something to give a
subsidy to Wood manufacturers or
furnaces that burn wood then come out in
the open and pass a tax this is
government at its worst it has nothing
to do with electric production it's just
good lobbyists and they've got this in
there and your electric rate payers who
are always complaining about the rates
are paying higher rates that they don't
even know to subsidize some large
furnace someplace some companies so they
can make more profits by burning would
and I urge you to push the red
button J recognize representative
V thank you Mr
Speaker while my good friend and
distinguished
colleague from the member from
straford did not say anything that was
wrong what he negle neglected to mention
was the significant County Municipal and
School District taxpayer savings that
result from the renewable energy credits
for class one
thermal to give you a few
examples number one the Rockingham
County Complex in Rockingham County
Heats its nursing home its jails and all
its facilities with
wood the State House the state
Courthouse rather and the county Hill
building in chesher County also have a
Woodfired boiler that they Heat their
building with the Compton school
district has a wood boiler that heats
the Compton Elementary School the
Peterboro town library has a biomass
thermal heating and cooling
system these are examples of extensive
public
buildings that
generate these thermal wrecks and reduce
the cost that rate that taxpayers have
to pay to support these
facilities now in addition to
that encouraging wood burning supports
our forest products industry and as
you'll all recall in 2023 that industry
took a big hit when the burg biop power
plant
was significantly impacted by The veto
of a bill that the house
passed and the Senate passed it for that
matter and the governor's veto was
upheld so our committee decided that
rather than add insult to injury to the
forest
industry that it would be prudent to
allow this bill to
uh be judged to be itl so that taxpayers
could continue to enjoy
the decrease in their costs that result
from the sale of these thermal bricks so
I urge you to vote green to support the
committee position and thank you Mr
Speaker representative Harrington has
requested a division members take your
seats this there will be a division
boote
the motion before us is a majority
committee report of itl on House Bill
166 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Harrington for
a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know the rate payers in say straford
County should not be high paying higher
electric bills to subsidize the rate
payers in Rockingham County and if I
know that we all talk about transparency
in government we don't want hidden fees
and special interest groups getting paid
for money that people don't even know
they're spending but I then vote for
transparent but I if I know about voting
for transparency in government I would
push the red
button jerck recognize your
representative VES for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that County Municipal and
School District taxpayers recognize
significant
savings by the sale of renewable energy
certificates under class one
thermal what I press the green button
to back up the committee's report of itl
on this bill a 19 to1 decision thank you
Mr Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
majority committee report of itl on
House Bill 166 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
91 represent Juliet
Smith representative Julie
Smith all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
State the
vote 319 voting yay 53 voting nay
committee report is adopted
committee on science technology and anud
to which was referred House Bill 381 act
relative to the system's benefits charge
having considered the same report the
same the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate Senator
Doug Thomas for the committee are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those opposed nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted
committee on science acknowledging any
to which was referred House Bill 458 an
act relative to participation in the net
energy metering by small hydroelectric
generators having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment Sen Tom
pagi from committee the amendment is 2
347h printed in house record 49 Pages 7
4 through
75 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay eyes have it an
amendment is adopted the question before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the committee report is
adopted committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill 609 FN act relative to energy
facility sighting considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment no
Michael V for the committee the
amendment 2368 H printed in house record
49 Pages 90- 92 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay eyes have
it and the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oos nay the eyes have it and the
committee report is
adopted committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill 631 FN act relative to electric
utility smart meter Gateway devices
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate pres of Doug
Thomas for the committee chair
recognized representative
Ms thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
colleagues and happy New Year I rise in
opposition to the motion of inexpedient
to legislate there is not a single
member of this body or the body on the
other side of the wall who does not want
to do something about the high cost of
electricity in our state it is impacting
families and hampering our ability to
retain exist in businesses let alone
attract new ones we are all United on
that where we differ is whether we are
willing to enact short-term temporary
rate reductions or begin to encourage
meaningful Investments that will result
in long-term sustainable rates for all
of us to those of you who may be
inclined to vote in favor of the motion
of inexpedient to
legislate understand that this bill will
not raise the cost of electricity
on the other hand a vote to overturn the
motion of inexpedient to legislate will
give individual consumers an opportunity
to save money in the short term and will
have a small and will be a small step
towards enabling the smarter management
of electric use that saves energy and
benefits all of us the only thing hb631
does is direct our three regulated
utilities eversource Unitil and Liberty
utilities to inform their customers that
they have the option to purchase a smart
meter Gateway device it is then up to
each individual consumer to decide
whether they want to install one of
those devices their choice no
mandate smart meter gateways are devices
installed inside a home or business and
are controlled by the home or business
owner they help to monitor electricity
consumption allowing the the household
or business the opportunity to more
effectively manage their energy usage
and hopefully reduce their energy costs
hb631 does not mandate that New
Hampshire utilities purchase an
inventory of devices the only thing
those utilities are required to do is
inform their customers which devices are
consistent with best practices and
supportive of features needed to run a
21st century grid
the cost to install a smart meter
Gateway device will be borne by the
consumer who chooses to purchase it
there is no cost shifting to any other
rate payer and there is no requirement
that those devices must be installed by
the utility HB 631 specifically says
that work can be done by approved
contractors the suggestion made in the
house record that installing a smart
meter Gateway device is like buying a
computer with no software support is
misleading the software to measure and
record electricity consumption is
installed in these devices consumers can
save money by reducing their energy
consumption and shifting their usage to
off- Peak periods those savings ACR to
customers whether or not the device is
connected to the utility that provides
the power to that household or business
all this bill does is encourage the
adoption of modern meters so that anyone
who is interested and saving money can
do so most of these devices are also
able through the internet to connect to
utility companies or energy power
vendors to manage power consumption with
the right incentives and or rewards in
place there are significant additional
benefits available to utilities from
operational efficiency greater
reliability and customer service gain by
managing Peak demand and reducing losses
and outages how we achieve those
benefits is is quite frankly a
discussion for another day and really
not part of this bill there is nothing
in this bill that requires any of our
utilities to connect to or support any
device their customer chooses to
purchase the only requirement is that
eversource Unitil and Liberty Utilities
let their customers know what type of
meter they can buy if they're interested
in doing so hb631 was submitted with the
knowledge that smarter meters are
already standard in some states and we
should be encouraging people to learn
what is available if they want to
actively manage their own electric bills
we are at a critical juncture in how we
address the energy challenges we Face
consumers are looking for ways to reduce
their energy costs installing gate smart
meter Gateway devices will give those
who decide to purchase one the
opportunity to do so we also need to
more aggressively upgrade our power grid
more more advanced state-of-the-art
meters are not the only thing we need to
do but they are as small albeit
important part of the solution by
encouraging our utilities to identify
Dei devices that would be most
compatible with their plans for future
system upgrades now hb631 will help to
minimize future redundancy and future
investment costs please join me in
voting no on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate so that another motion
may be made thank you Mr Speaker and I
request a roll call
vote do I recognize your representative
Thomas thank you Mr
Speaker
well my good friend from
Hampton has a good
argument but it reminds me of a movie I
saw from my cousin Vinnie when the when
they the the pro was asked does it hold
water and the answer was it does
not what the prime reason the prime
problem is with this bill is that the
bill refers to smart meter Gateway
devices smart meter Gateway devices are
not smart
meters Smart Meters come with software
and support to make them run and operate
and they're available now through
programs offered by source and other
utilities
smart Gateway devices are components
that will fit into electric meters or
other devices uh to make them operate
and these are not supported by software
or programs uh they are not offered for
support by by the electric utilities so
this bill has very good intentions but
there's two things about it is it
necessary and does and is it practical
and the answer is it it does Nei it is
not necessary and it's not practical and
I'll tell you
why besides RSA 374 Su colon 62 that
does uh require utilities to inform
customers if they are going to inst
install a smart meter uh this bill would
require utilities to provide a smart
meter Gateway device upon
request um
[Music]
so stop being supported by your software
so so the the the analogy of of
something like a computer without
operating system is sort of uh correct
in that you can you can get you can get
a device you can have it installed in
your meter but there is no support
behind it there is no design behind it
and the and the utilities do not offer
that uh that support so you're you have
something installed that is relatively
useless uh um thirdly uh secondly it's
not required because not necessary
because utilities already offer energy
survey uh energy saving programs like
smart meters like smart thermostats that
you can get and they and you can enroll
in their program and you can begin
saving uh money on energy immediately so
these programs already exist which and
and the technology that runs these
programs is preferred over the smart
meter Gateway devices so that's another
reason why this bill is not
necessary and again from a practical
point of view um I as I I mentioned
before there the smart meter gway
devices are not supportable so you're
buying something that unless someone
designs or a third party designs
additional software at some expense
they're not going to work and the
utilities don't provide that that
support so you know this bill
well-intentioned but it it just doesn't
doesn't hold water so the the committee
heard testimony to this effect and
agreed 11 to9 that really do we need an
unnecessary bill that is not practical
in order to show people that we are
trying to do something to lower costs I
don't think that's a way to show people
we're lowering costs this bill does not
do that and therefore I strongly
recommend you support the committee's
recommendation of
itl
representative Ms requested a roll call
is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
the motion before us is the committee
report of inexp to legisla House Bill
631 this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Wendy
Thomas for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that we
were that we are all concerned about the
high cost of electricity in New
Hampshire and if I know that this bill
will have no negative impact on
electrical rates but instead it will
Direct are three regulated utilities to
inform their customers of the option to
purchase a smart meter Gateway device
which is a tool for monitoring usage
throughout the day and finally if I also
know that by using these meters and
looking at the results consumers can
save money by reducing their energy
consumption and shifting their usage to
off peak periods
would I now save our rapers and
ourselves a boatload of money by
pressing the red button on inexpedient
to legislate so that another smarter
motion can be
made chair recognizes representative
Bernardi for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know requiring a utility to
sell a smart meter Gateway
device without time of Service rates
available from the utility to make it
work is like buying requiring a
manufacturer to sell you that computer
that has no operating
system knowing that would I push
no on and use the green button to record
that
device the motion before us is uh the
committee report of inexp to legisla and
House Bill 631 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent Smith
all members present and opportunity to
vote El will attend to stay to the
vote 192 voting a 180 voting nay
committee report is
adopted
Tom
committee on state and federal relations
and Veterans Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 229 FN relative to
requirement an official declaration of
war for the activation of New Hampshire
National Guard this comes without
recommendation pres Tom man moves ought
to
pass representative power has a floor
Amendment house will be in
order
045h it is in your seat Pockets there is
no debate on the floor Amendment are you
ready for the
question representative power is
recognized to speak to a floor
Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in support
of the floor amendment to House Bill
229 Mr Speaker in order to fully
comprehend this amendment it is
important to understand three key
Concepts first by definition the
National Guard is not a state militia
state militias are distinct from the
National Guard and that they serve no
federal function the state of New
Hampshire does not have a state
militia second the National Guard
normally under State Control becomes
part of the Federal Reserve components
of the United States Army and the United
States Air Force when activated for
federal missions and third the National
Guard operates under three different
statuses title 10 status which is
federally funded and federally
controlled under the command and control
of the president title 32 status which
is federally funded and state controlled
under the command and control of the
state or territory governor and state
Act of Duty which is state funded and
state controlled under the command and
control of the state territory or
Governor therefore the National Guard is
under the Dual control of the state and
the federal governments now this
amendment clarifies the definition of
active duty combat to include direct
combat service in an armed conflict or
combat service support employing an
instrumentality of war in support of an
armed conflict both being hazardous du
duties to be clear this definition
includes Frontline service members as
well as service members supporting the
front lines both deployed under title 10
furthermore this amendment removes the
Clause performance of a Duty through an
instrumentality of War as a standalone
provision from the definition of active
duty
combat where an instrumentality of war
is defined as a vehicle vessel device or
equipment designated primarily for
military
service this change is important since
most missions performed by the National
Guard are distinct from active duty
combat and they involve the use of
instrumentalities of War duties that
involve
the use of an instrumentality of War
include most National Guard weekend
drills deployments training exercises
Statewide State Side emergency responses
as well as humanitarian and Civic
assistance such duties also include
deployments to to provide training and
assistant to Friendly foreign military
units through the National Guard State
partnership program to be clear none of
these missions of the National Guard
constitute active duty combat but they
do involve the use of instrumentalities
of war and these important missions
would be prohibited by the bill without
this amendment lastly sections five and
six of the amendment are
self-evident and that they simply
reaffirm that these non-active Duty
combat missions are allowed with this
amendment Mr Speaker in closing this
amendment makes important and necessary
adjustments to the language of House
Bill
229 therefore I urge my fellow
colleagues to vote Yes to support the
floor Amendment and then the bill as
amended thank you Mr
Speaker question before the house is the
power floor Amendment
0045 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the floor amendment
is adopted the motion before us now was
ought to pass as amended chair
recognizes representative s
nasto thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
stand before you with a profound sense
of Duty my my service in the 82nd
Airborne Division as a combat medic
where I was honored with the combat
medic badge for treating casualties
Under Fire shapes my understanding of
the gravity of sending our troops into
combat this bill requires the US
Congress to formally declare war before
deployment of New Hampshire National
Guard troops into
combat the United States Constitution
gives Congress the power to declare war
in part to ensure that grave decisions
were subject to rigorous debate
representative consent and transparency
this process was designed to prevent
unchecked executive power and to
guarantee that the will of the people
through their elective Representatives
Was Heard and heeded by sidest stepping
this process Congress is not held
accountable for the outcomes and
consequences of military
engagements defend the guard is not an
impediment to our National Guard's
capacity to defend our nation and
respond to emergencies instead it
fortifies the Constitutional process
requiring a formal declaration of war by
Congress before our troops are sent into
Cong combat this doesn't prevent
deployment it ensures that such a
significant decision is made with a full
deliberation and Authority that only a
congressionally approved uh declared war
can
provide our national Guardsmen can be
called into service under two distinct
codes title 10 and title 32 of the US
code title 10 places our Guardsmen under
presidential command for National
Defense while title 32 keeps them under
State command primarily for domestic
emergencies this bill continues New
Hampshire's compliance with both the
issue is that Congress has not formally
declared war since World War II instead
the authorization for use of military
force aumf of 2001 has been used as a
blanket justification for military
actions worldwide the aumf has led to
endless engagements with no
accountability or oversight from those
who initiated it this is not only a
legal misstep but a moral failure and it
puts our troops in global stability at
risk without proper justification or end
strategy concerns about losing Federal
funding due to due to non-compliance
with title 10 and 32 are overstated as
outlined in section 108 of title 32 the
president has discretion in this and
also must provide a time frame for
states to address any compliance issues
before Financial consequences moreover
the political reality is that it is
improbable for the federal government to
withdraw funding from the National Guard
an institution that enjoys widespread
public support no politician will ever
Advocate to withhold funding to the
National
Guard the New Hampshire government role
is not to hold water for the US Congress
but to uphold the principles of the
Constitution and protect the interests
and rights of its citizens allowing
Congress to bypass its Duty not only
undermines the Constitutional framework
but it also diminishes the voice and
repes representation of our constituents
in matters of
War defend the guard resonates deeply
with our citizens across political
divides I have found unanimous support
for this bill this is a decision that
impacts the lives of our servicemen and
women and the Constitutional integrity
of our nation before we ask New
Hampshire guards men and women to go to
foreign lands to kill and be killed we
should first ask Congress to do its job
and make a formal declaration of war
thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
Shir thank you m thank you Mr Speaker um
Mr Speaker uh with all due respect from
my friend from De and he is my friend uh
I Rise to oppose this
bill uh when the bill first came to our
committee I got a lot of calls from
people in New Hampshire and a few from
out of New Hampshire and the last thing
they'd say to me is uh and don't forget
veterans support this
bill and uh and let me say nobody hates
War other than those that have lost a
loved one more than a
veteran and I haven't fought in a war a
long time ago and Far Away along with my
friend from
havil
know that
um the agonies of
War but I'm a veteran and I don't
support this
bill and um and that feeling was
reinforced when the state veterans
advisory Council met for those that
don't know and I know a lot of you do
know about the council it's a state
agency
uh is chaired by Paul Lloyd the past
commander of the New Hampshire VFW and a
real friend of veterans and it's made up
of 20 different veterans organizations
uh uh VFW uh Korean war vets uh American
Legion Vietnam Veterans of
America
um military order of the purple hat and
so many others and that organization on
a vote of 2010 to nothing voted not to
support this bill but to oppose
it
now this is not a good bill it's not
good for the National Guard it's not
good for New Hampshire it's not good for
our country and for me most importantly
it's not good for members on active duty
of the Armed Forces and I should mention
we have a member from the legislature
that also serves on the state advisory
committee and doesn't excellent
job it's not good for the National Guard
because as I said in my blurb we get uh
up to2 Billion a year from the
Department of Defense a lot of that goes
into planes for the Air National Guard
goes into paying for personnel it goes
into buying the helicopters that we
often see on Channel 9 News bringing
somebody down from the mountains who's
been injured it does so much for our
state
that could be a Jeopardy for our
National Guard now you someone may speak
later and say oh no the Pentagon won't
take away that two billion they got
plenty of money they'll keep giving it
to New Hampshire not if you get a
National Guard that can't react
immediately to uh a National Defense
issue uh this bill as I mentioned is not
good for New Hampshire because we do get
a lot of services from our national
guard that stay right here in this state
and help so much whether it's Engineers
or anything else a lot of that money
that goes to support those programs will
be gone it won't be good for our country
and it won't be good for our active duty
military the last time Congress passed
the declaration of war was on December
11th
1941 when our country declared war on
Germany 4 days after Pearl habo was
attacked and if we learn nothing else
from World War II we learned that this
country is no longer a citadel we do not
stand alone and have the Atlantic in the
Pacific to protect us from our enemies
abroad if something happens like in
1950 when North Korea came over the 48th
parallel and attacked South
Korea we had to react immediately and we
did along with the United
Nations we now have a complete Nut Job
running North Korea Kim Kim Yung on
who's got a missile that can hit the
United States if he should again decide
to attack Korea we've got to act
immediately when I served in Vietnam the
17 field artillery was stationed there
too of the National Guard and there only
a couple of Miles where from where I was
at Li K with the first division second
Brigade they fought with honor and they
fought with sacri riced by that unit I
was proud to have them there and
partners even more so today when our
national gu is part of that tapestry of
United States defense all the agencies
and all the Departments weave together
as one solid force in defense of our
nation we got some more bills and we've
been here a long time already I'm going
to end now but I please ask you to vote
no on this so another motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize representative Tom
Manion thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of HB 229 commonly referred to
as the defend the guard act this bill
very simply requires Congress to
formally declare war pursuant to Article
1 Section 8 of the US Constitution
before we will deploy our State National
Guard to a foreign combat zone it does
not stop training deployments natural
disaster response used to repel Invasion
or quell uprisings it has been filed in
38 States and is making progress through
various legislatures the fiscal note
attached to this bill a vague puts
funding at risk is the same tired Hollow
threat the feds used bully States into
compliance it's intentionally
non-committal because it's nonsense when
filed in Kansas defend the guard was
reported accurately as having no fiscal
impact Congress congressman goser and
Massie have spoken in favor of this bill
reminding us that Congress controls the
purse strings and no member would
consider defunding a guard unit it
simply would be political suicide to
file an amendment to an Appropriations
Bill defunding a single state guard
being both a petty Act of malice and
also making the country weaker it will
not happen now for a bit of History
Congress has not formally declared war
since 1942 42 the War Powers Resolution
of
1973 uh introduced the authorizations
for use of military force which have
been the mechanism by which the
presidents have executed military
operations ever since this abdication of
constitutionally delegated power to the
executive branch ultimately led us into
forever Wars of the last two decades the
2001 aumf was hastily passed in the wake
of 911 and was so vastly worded with
vague limits on targets theaters of oper
ation and no Victory conditions that has
been the justification for military
action in 22 countries over the course
of the war on terror National Guard
units made up 45% of the boots on the
ground in Afghanistan Iraq and Syria
accounting for 18% of the casualties
hurricane Katrina's Devastation in 2005
was exacerbated by Guard soldiers and
equipment that were deployed to Iraq and
Kuwait instead of at home protecting
their communities years later one of the
same missing Louisiana National Guard
units the 256th infantry Brigade came
under rocket attacks during their
deployment to Syria in 2021 where the US
is occupying that country's oil fields
the Pentagon will continue to exploit
State guard units to bolster their
shrinking ranks in these forever Wars
until the states say enough is enough
asking people to vote harder in federal
elections to beg our represent
representatives to repeal the a umfs has
been a failing proposition to stop the
uni party war machine for decades the
most recent vote in the US Senate to
repeal the 2001 aumf garnered 10 votes
this is in our hands right now to
protect the lives of the servicemen and
women in our state and to ensure our
guard remains always ready always there
I ask you to stand with them defend the
guard and press the green button to OTP
HB 229 and Mr Speaker I asked for a roll
call
vote House of be in order you does the
member yield the
questions thank you Mr speaker thank you
representative for taking my question uh
last March 29th we uh we delivered a
proclam house proclamation to uh to a
national godsman here in uh he was from
Windam and uh you know he uh he won
soldier of the year he's uh he's now
stationed over in Kuwait and uh would
you believe you know I I was talking to
him a week and a half or so ago and uh
you know they they're all all him him
and his uh his fellow soldiers are very
aware of what we're doing here right now
and uh and they have asked for our
support I do believe that uh the the
there's resounding support amongst uh
post 911 veterans there is a disconnect
with the svac committee that I'm looking
to rectify next year with legislation
thank
you representative Granger has requested
a roll call as that sufficiently second
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
clear the motion before us is aut to
passes amended in House Bill
229 this will be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
Massa for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know the title 10 of the US
code
outlines the authority of the federal
government to activate the reserves
including the National Guard in time of
war or of a national emergency or when
otherwise authorized by law law and that
a governor may not withhold consent in
whole or part with regards to active
duty deployment outside of the United
States and if I know that Congress in
2001 passed the authorization of the use
of military force act which empowered
the president to use all necessary and
appropriate Force against Nations
organizations and persons dealing in
Acts of international terrorism against
the United States and that the aumf ACT
has been used to activate combat
activities against ter terrorist groups
abroad without a declaration of war for
the past 19 years and finally Mr
Speaker although I believe HB
229 is well intended as we all want to
keep our New Hampshire National
Guardsmen out of Harm's Way but I also
know that the department of military
Affairs and veteran services opposed
this bill Bill and that it would create
a conflict between the state and federal
laws and the supremacy clause of the
United States
Constitution and can only be resolved at
the federal
level would I now press the red
button to uh uh against the otpa thank
you chair recognize representative Reed
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know members of Congress have reaffirmed
that Congress certainly will not take
the unprecedented move of defunding a
state Guard unit and certainly not the
committee chaired by one of New
Hampshire's own
senators and certainly not for New
Hampshire affirming that it should be
Congress and not one man one person who
makes the dire Last Resort decision to
send the National Guard into overseas
war and if I know that we have spent
over two decades thousands of lives and
trillions of dollars to enrich oil
companies and defense contractors while
destabilizing the Middle East and
souring an entire generation against the
United States and finally Mr Speaker if
I know that as the name implies the
place for the National Guard is here at
home guarding the nation where they will
be available to help us during the next
pandemic or natural disaster or civil
unrest would I now then press the green
button to defend the guard who defends
us the motion before us is a pass as
amended on House Bill 229 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor your Pres
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state to the
vote the house of will be in
order with 187 voting yay 182 voting nay
committee report is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise uh may I request that the debate on
that bill be placed in the permanent
Journal uh the debate on the previous
Bill may it be placed in the permanent
Journal please without
objection
all right 229 the bill that was just
voted on is going to
finance
majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred
House Bill 375 FN act relative to lure
of non-resident aliens temporarily
residing in New Hampshire considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate s of Ted gski from the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
oh minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with them majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative George SES from the
minority of the
committee chair recognize representative
sodi I'd like to make a motion to State
your motion uh to table HB
375 the motion is a table HB
375 are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
this will be a division on the table in
motion
so he'll do a pi hold
on he'll do a pi
against
s
the motion before us is tbling of House
Bill 375 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative
Walch thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that this bill has a major flaw
and that was recognized at our public
hearing if I know that uh the major flaw
actually would be harmful to the people
this bill seeks to benefit rather than
help them and Mr Speaker if I also know
that it's not the habit of this house to
send bills with major flaws to the other
side of the wall before we fix them
would I now press the green
button chair recognizes representative
Sykes for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues if I
know that as you consider the question
of tabling this bill several relevant
points might be considered and should be
considered and furthermore I know that
the transportation committee retained
this bill last year because of the sense
that there was a problem and that we
should work on a
solution and finally if I know that this
bill might have come to the floor on a
different day as ought to pass and it's
an important principle I repeat it's an
important
principle of this legislature that a
Bill's merits should we have a debate on
the floor what I now ask you allow that
floor vote by voting against the tabling
motion and allowing a short one-on-one
debate
thank you Mr Speaker motion before us is
to table House Bill 375 this is a
division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
repres all members present have
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 185 voting yay 179 voting a three
House Bill 375 is light on the
table
majority committee on transportation to
which was referred House Bill 570
relative to re real ID compliant New
Hampshire driver's licenses consider the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate s of Thomas Walsh from
majority of the
committee chair recognize the
representative
Walsh thank you Mr Speaker I move to
table House Bill
570 Senor Walsh moves to table House
Bill
570 a division has been requested
members stay in your
seats and take your
seats
for the motion before us is the table
House Bill 570 this is a division vote
chair recognize representative Walsh for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the department of safety
through the Department of Motor Vehicles
has already adopted the requirements
from the real ID Act that they saw
prudent and responsible which makes this
bill unnecessary when I now press the
green
button do J recognize represent Val for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that there are other
important aspects to the real ID that
have not been considered that we should
have that we should debate here today
would I now hit the red button to defeat
the tabling motion so we can discuss
this issue
further
uh I'll try to do it again um if I
know okay if I know that there are
issues around the real ID law that need
to be addressed in
2025 the real regular driver's licenses
will no longer be valid for federal
purposes at airports it's important that
we have this debate now what I now hit
the red button to defeat the tabling
motion thank you the motion before us is
the table House Bill 570 this is a
division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent love
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote El will attend to
state of the
vote 187 voting yay 180 voting nay House
Bill 570 is laid on the table
all right sir we here we go
these are two
amendments got
it
the majority of the committee on ways
and means to which was referred House
Bill 121 FN an act relative to worldwide
combined reporting for unitary
businesses under the business profits
tax having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Walter
spillsbury for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
Thomas shamberg for the minority of the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate representative shamberg is
recognized speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker I come
before for you to ask for your help to
write a
wrong some will try to complicate this
but it's really very simple under our
current business profits tax structure
BPT foreign companies doing business in
New Hampshire get a pass under a
provision known as Water's Edge but New
Hampshire businesses must pay the full
tax our tax laws put our own companies
our own Neighbors at a competitive
disadvantage to foreign
competitors now that's just not my
opinion the New Hampshire Supreme Court
wrote in a 1999 decision that and I
quote The Waters Edge provision was
adopted for the benefit of foreign
businesses in a deal with then British
prime minister Maggie Thatcher the US
and foreign governments essentially
threatened the states into adopting
Waters Edge provision since
1986 when New Hampshire adopted Waters
Edge domestic businesses have operated
under an
anti-competitive and unequal tax burden
compared to foreign
Enterprises even before the US
government began pushing states to adopt
Water's Edge in the mid1
1980s then treasury secretary James
Baker wrote that I quote if a foreign
Only Solution were adopted it could
reasonably be argued that domestically
controlled businesses were thereby
disadvantaged prior to 1986 New
Hampshire operated under what is known
as worldwide combined
reporting it was supposed to require all
companies domestic and foreign to
transparen
transparently report all activities
worldwide so that an accurate tax
liability for activities in New
Hampshire could be
determined but for some reason the New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration in the early
1980s chose not to enforce the law
against foreign companies
my esteemed colleagues on the other side
recognized in the 2023 commission report
on this issue to the Ways and Means
Committee that the dr's policy was
discriminatory and probably
unconstitutional never mind that it
ignored state law but in adopting Waters
Edge we simply codified that
discrimination House Bill 121 will write
that wrong leveling the playing field in
business
Taxation and the institute on Taxation
and economic policy found that ending
Waters Edge and enacting worldwide
combined reporting could increase state
revenue by
$177 million annually with no impact on
New Hampshire businesses or taxpayers
with the pressures facing property
taxpayers and public schools why
wouldn't we end this anti- competitive
practice but by a narrow 10 to9 margin
Ways and Means Committee recommends that
house bill
is inexpedient to
legislate they want you to vote to
continue protecting foreign companies
from taxation at the expense of New
Hampshire businesses you're probably
asking why vote to change a tax policy
called Waters Edge tax method that from
1986 is the largest single generator of
state tax revenue through the business
profits tax each year the most important
value we all strive for in our
legislature is equal treatment under the
law for our
citizens equal treatment is not just the
overriding principle of Taxation policy
in ways and
means it is The Guiding Light of the
rule of law in a
democracy present domestic companies and
businesses in the granite state must
fully document sales activities and pay
their full tax liability Under The
Waters Edge policy while the same tax
policy permits foreign Enterprises to
escape such
documentation and full tax liability
which is clearly
anti-competitive and obviously
discriminatory it is now a moral and
legal decision that each of us must make
on this itl
recommendation but one fully in keeping
with our belief in free and Fair
competition I also know a vote for the
itl motion today which is a vote to
punish New Hampshire businesses to
protect foreign ones is a vote that will
be remembered come
November we need to promote our value
system of equal treatment under our New
Hampshire Constitution by pushing the
red button so we may introduce a
nondiscriminatory bill House Bill 121
worldwide combined reporting thank you
Mr Speaker and I ask for a roll call
vote representative Lee please recognize
to speak against the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker I've heard it said that New
Hampshire State reps aren't the most
imaginative
people but I'd like you to use your
imagination for a
moment after a long day at the State
House not exactly a stretch of the
imagination you deserve a treat so you
get in your car you oh before you get in
your car you walk across the street to
Revel Stoke for a mocha latte it's six
bucks but you've earned it and it's
delicious
the next day after another long day in
the State House you've earned another
treat but you forget to get it before
you get to your car so you stop by that
new Starbucks in the Market Basket
parking lot you get another mocha latte
and it's another six bucks but it's also
delicious now to be clear you actually
pay
$651 for each $6 mocha because you pay
an8 .5% room in meals tax which goes
straight to the state coffers that tax
is
transparent right there on the receipt
and it's the same whether you pay it at
Rebel Stoke or at
Starbucks but what about business
profits tax the BPT do Revelstoke and
Starbucks pay the same business profit
tax on that $6 latte they should right
assuming for the sake of argument that
they labor lease paper and other costs
are the same we would assume that when
these two companies pay their New
Hampshire BPT they would pay the same
amount right it would only be fair but
that's not what happens because while
Revel Stoke sends the taxes on their
profits across the street the profits
from that Starbucks 500 yards away
travel halfway across the globe before
any taxes on them make it to conquered
I'm not just talking about a trip to
Starbucks HQ in Seattle I'm talking
about an accounting junket to tax Havens
like Ireland Switzerland and the
Netherlands while Revel Stoke declares
$2 of profit when they make $2 on a
latte Starbucks doesn't do that they pay
a shell company in the Netherlands for
the intellectual property rights to use
the Starbucks logo and name because
that's where intellectual property taxes
are
lowest tax Havens around the world cater
to these multinationals charging them
extremely low taxes on Specialized
Financial transactions to transfer
profits to themselves enabling them to
avoid taxes due to the places they
actually make their money so by the time
they're done transferring profits around
the world to wherever the the tax policy
costs them the least
multinationals like Starbucks can
actually declare a loss on that mocha
sold here in conquered and thus avoid
paying any tax due on that
profit this means that Revel Stoke and
its one store here in coner is
shouldering the load for multinationals
like Starbucks with its 29 stores across
the state and if Revel Stoke is paying
15 cents on every single latte in New
Hampshire and Starbucks is shielding
their profit from that tax then
Starbucks is really making 15 cents more
per latte even when they're charging the
same price and have the same
costs that's 15 cents per latte that
Starbucks can use to outcompete Revel
Stoke having a hard time hiring
Starbucks can outp Revel stoke
economy getting tight Starbucks can
lower their
prices getting the vibe that people
really want to buy local Starbucks could
launch a marketing campaign saying how
good they are for the local
economy while sending their profits to
the Netherlands to avoid paying local
taxes this is not free and Fair
competition article 83 part two of the
New Hampshire
Constitution
says and I quote free and Fair
competition in the trades and industries
is an inherent and essential right of
the people and should be protected
against all monopolies and conspiracies
which tend to hinder or destroy
it the size and functions of all
corporations should be so limited and
regulated as to prohibit fictitious
capital ation and provision should be
made for the supervision and government
thereof therefore all just power
possessed by the state is hereby granted
to the general court that's us to enact
laws to prevent the operations within
the state of all persons and
associations and all trust and
corporations foreign or domestic and the
officers thereof who Endeavor to raise
the price of any article of Commerce or
to destroy free and Fair competition in
the trades and industries through
combination conspiracy Monopoly or any
other unfair means to control and
regulate the acts of all such persons
associations corporations trusts and
officials doing business within the
state to prevent fictitious
capitalization and to authorize civil
and criminal proceedings in respect to
all the wrongs herein declared
against end of
quote on December 7th
2022 we all of us here swore an oath to
uphold the new Hamp the New Hampshire
Constitution so when we expect local
companies to pay their tax taxes on the
profits they make here in New Hampshire
but we enable large multinational
companies like Starbucks and their teams
of creative accountants and lawyers to
avoid paying those same taxes on the
very same
profits We are failing to do the job we
were elected to
do our constituents are drowning in
property
taxes and everybody run running for
office talks about how important small
businesses are to our communities and to
our
economy if we want to continue to be a
state without an income tax without a
broad-based sales tax and still function
as a state we cannot continue to let
these multinationals play three card
Monty with New Hampshire's money that's
why it's time to end the current tax
policy that lets multinational avoid
taxes on profits they make here in New
Hampshire while undercutting our small
businesses like Revel Stoke in the
process it is time for us to stand up
for ourselves stop letting these
multinationals steal our lunch money and
put an end to the unfair wat's Edge tax
policy please push the red button to
defeat the itl so another motion can be
made thank you Mr
Speaker final speaker on the bill and
members reminded a roll call was
requested so maybe start finding your
way back to your seats representative
spillsbury is recognized to speak for
the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker I'm feeling a little
disadvantaged with all of these seats
so I feel disadvantaged with all the
empty
seats there's been a lot of soaring
rhetoric I'd like to bring this back
down and anchor it in the
practicality of having workable tax
law so before explaining why you should
all vote to itl HP
1221 I want to review that history you
heard the federal government began
taxing business income in the early
1930s they require reporting of income
generated in the United
States they deal with
multinationals by requiring that any
intra corporate transfer
payments be adjusted if necessary to
reflect arms length pricing
so that it
dissuades and through audit perhaps
prevents shifting profits to lower tax
foreign
jurisdictions that arms length method is
what the IRS has used
uninterrupted since business income tax
was instituted in the early
30s New Hampshire adopted the business
profits tax at the beginning of the
1970s and followed the arms length
method but in a wave a
trend by the early 1980s New Hampshire
was one of about a dozen to 15 states
that adopted worldwide combined
reporting the theory of worldwide
combined
reporting is that you can
neutralize or
capture any ostensibly abusive transfer
payments to and from foreign Affiliated
entities by telling a corporation to
report to the state of New
Hampshire 100% of its worldwide
activity all of its
sales all of its profits in as many
countries as it operates in through as
many many Affiliated corporations as it
has sometimes in the
hundreds regardless of whether it's
upstream or Downstream to a parent
Corporation or a
subsidiary
well sounds
interesting but in practice it was never
enforced this regime in the early 80s
caused major International
objections serious diplomatic
problems and Drew The
Continuous uh
attention of the rean administration its
Department of Treasury and a major task
force the result of the pressure from
the federal
government as well as a rash of
litigation
that Rose to the United States Supreme
Court
twice was that states were
encouraged to get rid of worldwide
combined
reporting now just imagine what the
burden on a multinational corporation
would be under worldwide combined
reporting and by the way it does not
make a difference whether it's a
us-based corporation doing business
overseas or a foreign based Corporation
doing business
here and the suggestion that they're
treated differently under current law is
just simply
wrong as long as you sell something in
New Hampshire but you also sell
something somewhere elsewhere outside
the United States you would be drawn in
to these extraordinarily cumbersome
reporting
obligations
so it's for those kinds of reasons that
in
1986 the New Hampshire
legislature repealed worldwide combined
reporting and imposed waterers Edge
limitations and that's now been the law
for 38
years what The Waters Edge limitation
does is it allows for us to ask unitary
businesses operating amongst the States
to declare all of their activity in the
United States but that's actually an
enormous convenience because it aligns
our reporting requirements with those of
the Internal Revenue
Service so when a
business us-based or foreign-based
files its tax return with the IRS that's
the point of departure for now preparing
a New Hampshire business profits
tax so why
after 38 years are we supposed to be
motivated to go back to something that
every state
abandoned there is no
state that applies worldwide combined
reporting and if New Hampshire were to
adopt HB
1221 we would be reaching far beyond
what the Internal Revenue Service asks
for it's actually
difficult to even explain how
complicated that could get but I can
tell you that I used to work for a
multinational Shipping Company operating
in 78 countries and uh my personal tax
return because I lived in the
Netherlands for a couple of years was
about that big so you can only
imagine you've been told that hb21 is
simple the only thing simple about it is
the statement of its
intent there is nothing simple about it
from the standpoint of
implementation from the standpoint of
compliance from the standpoint of
monitoring or audit or
enforcement we're dealing with companies
that are
operating in a host of countries whose
legal systems are entirely different
whose tax regimes are entirely
different whose accounting
standards don't bear any relation to
ours whose languages are different whose
currencies are
different do not be swept in with the
idea that this is somehow an easy
solution it may be
true that transfer pricing can be used
in abusive ways but there are
initiatives on the international level
through the Oe ecd with our state
department and they have made
progress part of the progress was in the
tax cuts and jobs act when the corporate
uh tax rate was reduced from 36% to
21% corporations now have far less
incentive to shift profits
overseas part of it has been dealt with
through the guilty rules very Arcane I
won't get into it but when you're told
that we need to reinstate worldwide
combined reporting to level the planing
field or to eliminate unfair
practices you're getting a distorted
presentation as it stands right now A
New
Hampshire based domestic company that
does business only in New Hampshire just
has to file what it did here in New
hampsh
Hampshire a multi-state corporation has
to file what it does in 50 states in
order to make its presentation to New
Hampshire every other
Corporation is simply protected from
having to declare their worldwide
operations so I could go on I'll just
say
that if this was not complicated if this
was
simple the ways and means commit would
not have punted it would not have gone
to a statutory commission the statutory
commission would not have written a
16-page report with all kinds of
appendices and a bibliography of dozens
and dozens and dozens of scholarly
articles court cases and and and
essays the commission wouldn't have
voted six to one to kill this bill so be
practical
if this bill is passed I predict we will
spend years digging ourselves out of a
quagmire of
repercussions does a member yield for a
question thank you you may inquire
representative PL thank you for taking
my question representative spillsbury if
we were to adopt worldwide reporting
would it result in an increase in
revenues a decrease in revenues or a
crapshoot
the correct answer is C crapshoot it
would depend entirely on whether the
prophets overseas were lower or greater
which could vary by company and could
vary for a company from year to year we
have no way to
know before we move on I want to take a
moment I probably annoyed a couple of
people by doing an experiment there was
a complaint about noise and I did
nothing I didn't react cuz I wanted to
see well I wanted to learn and I did I
wanted to learn if there was one
particular group over the other I wanted
to see if the level was proportional at
all to the length of the speech here's
what I found started out kind of quiet
if you get like 5 minutes in not that it
is an excuse but then it starts to get
loud and I did notice that one side was
noticeably quieter than the other I'm
not going to name the culprits I just
want to remind you all if if you were
sitting there listening quietly and
respectfully thank you and if you
weren't you may be the one down here one
day struggling to be
heard representative shamberg repress a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
121 representative shirtliff was
recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you m thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that New
Hampshire's current tax law permits
foreign companies doing business in New
Hampshire to evade the business uh
profits tax and if I know that this
discrimin discri incriminates against
New Hampshire based businesses putting
them at a competitive disadvantage and
making them pay more than their fair
share and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that making foreign companies pay their
fair share of business taxes will
produce more revenue for our state
potentially up to
$177 million annually with no impact on
New Hampshire businesses or taxpayers
would I now press the red button thank
you Mr
Speaker representative Janan is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that no
other
state mandates worldwide combined
reporting and if I know that the
commission that studied this issue voted
six to one against recommending
worldwide combined
reporting and if I further know that the
implementation of combined worldwide
reporting would be a huge difficulty for
businesses and actually make New
Hampshire less competitive thereby
potentially lowering business profits
because companies would do Less business
in New Hampshire and finally if I know
that New Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration would have a very
difficult time ensuring compliance and
auditing would I support the itl motion
and press the green button thank you
the question before the house is a
majority committee report of been
expedient to legislate on House Bill 121
And this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor press the green button opposed
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 192 in the affirmative 76 and the
negative the report is
adopted the committee on ways and means
to which was referred House Bill 450 FN
an act relative to removing the net
operating loss deduction limit on
taxable income under the business
profits tax having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Walter spillsbury for the
committee the amendment is 2272 H
printed in house record 49 on page
74 questions on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the Amendments adopted
the question is now on the motion ought
to pass with Amendment ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay and the report is
adopted
the committee on ways and means to which
is referred House Bill 494 FN an act
relative to fees collected under the New
Hampshire fertilizer law having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Susan
Aly for the committee the amendment is
2342 H printed in house record 49 on
pages 79 and 80 the question is on the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
Amendments adopted question now is on
the motion of ought to pass with
amendments are you ready for that
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the report is
adopted the committee on ways and means
to which was referred Senate Bill 112 FN
an act relative to paramutual pools and
historic horse racing having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Fred
duett for the committee the amendment is
444h printed on house record 49 on pages
110 to 111 questions on the amendments
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I all those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted the questions now on the
majority report of O to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose Nay n the eyes have it and the
report is
adopted the majority of the committee on
ways and means to which was referred
Senate Bill 190 FN an act relative to
Advanced deposit account wagering having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Fred duett for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative Susan Aly for the
minority of the committee questions on
the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate are you ready
for the question all in V say I I all
those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the report is
adopted the house will now consider
bills removed from the consent
calendar
all right the committee on children and
family law to which was referred House
Bill 499 FN an act requiring The Rules
of Evidence to apply in family court
cases and relative to the admission of
certain evidence and family court
proceedings having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Mark Pearson for the committee
representative Hol is recognized to
speak against the committee
report
thank you Mr
Speaker why would I take a 16 to Zer
bill off
consent it's a good question it's worth
asking sure is that better thank you why
would I take a bill that's a 16 to zero
committee recommendation off consent
it's a question worth asking the blurb
in the house Cal is actually longer than
the text of the bill the text of the
bill is short so short it's two
sentences I'll read it in its entirety
so people understand what they're voting
on the court shall admit any evidence or
testimony in any form offered by the
respondent in a Family Division case
which the respondent believes will be
favorable to his or her case second
sentence in all proceedings before the
judicial branch Family Division the
court shall apply the New Hampshire
Rules of Evidence to enhance the
predictable orderly fair and and
reliable presentation of
evidence sounds
reasonable in fact our constitution
speaks to this but before I can get to
that I want to read two articles out of
part first freedom of speech the freedom
of deliberation speech and debate in
either in either House of the
legislature is so essential to the
rights of the people that it cannot be
the foundation of any action complaint
or prosecution in any Court or Place
whatsoever I'll explain why I bring that
up in a minute
second constitutional principle that is
worthwhile rights of the accused part 1
Article 15 no subject shall be held to
answer for any crime or offense until
the same is fully and plainly
substantially and formally described to
him or be compelled to accuse or furnish
evidence against himself every subject
shall have the right to produce all
proofs not some not most it's all proofs
that may be favorable to himself or to
meet Witnesses against him face to face
and to be fully heard in his defense by
himself or his
counsel I can go on there's more to that
article it's an important
article so I'm going to go back in
history a little bit as a
dad a little over two years
ago one of my children was having some
medical issues we did appropriate due
diligence as parents to treat said
medical
issues we went and saw the emerg went to
the emergency room we saw several other
doctors I had a nurse who believed we
were doing the wrong thing and made a
mandatory phone call to
DCF I remember that day quite well
because I get a phone call from a 20 603
271 phone number that I don't
know and it's a dcyf employee demanding
that my child go immediately to the
emergency room now mind you the that
same child had been released from the
emergency room pirate or 6 days earlier
and had been released to go home by the
nurse that
morning she changed her
mind I told the dcyf employee because I
knew more about the medication than the
nurse that I don't think her analysis is
correct I'm pretty certain it's
faulty her analysis is fundamentally
flawed for for numerous medical reasons
and I could easily describe those so
then no there's no need to go to an
emergency room but I will gladly go to a
doctor of my choice anywhere in the
state if you need me to go get this
opinion confirmed no that wasn't good
enough we need to see your child in an
emergency room right
now imminent danger of coma or
death say that again imminent danger
imminent being the key word of coma or
death mind you that child is healthy
well and doing well at home right now so
imminent danger of coma or death is
probably a little bit of an
exaggeration this then went into the
typical process that parents see if
they're accused of neglect or abuse by a
state agency in this case
DCF there's a hearing at a court that's
a good thing we had one of those about a
week
later between the initial accusation and
the court hearing which was on a
Thursday my son saw two additional
doctors on Friday dcyf spoke with one of
those doctors and had a video phone call
with my son and my
wife and they still continued to push
for removal of it of him from the
home a week
later imminent danger of coma or
death so we get to this first hearing at
the court and we agree to a set an order
that the judge signs off that was
mutually agreed to by all parties I
won't read the entire order it was
written by
hand but I will read two or three key
lines the expart order issued in this
matter is amended as follows dcyf shall
not seek placement outside the home
until further court order child shall
remain with his
parents I'm going to go on the last one
is the most important right above the
signature of of the judge
the scheduling of said hearing meaning
the first preliminary evidential
evidentiary
hearing shall account for the
availability of the father's medical
Witnesses all of whom shall be able to
testify
telephonically not most not some all of
whom shall be able to testify
telephonically December
16th Christmas rolls around there's lots
going on unfortunately the court C the
court and the department can't meet the
statutory requirements to have a
follow-up Hearing in the right amount of
time so it's January 21st before we're
back in court
again one would think I would have time
to have at the next
hearing the emergency room Doctor Who
saw my son the day after the initial
accusation to come testify cuz I was
just told he would be allowed to testify
so I paid an emergency room doctor to
sit in the hallway at the conquered City
Court
house
unfortunately he didn't get a chance to
testify so we get to that 21st order and
I'm going to read another court order
the following orders and this is coming
out of the hearing on the 21st the
following orders are entered following
this hearing couple different
things the case will be scheduled for a
three area 3-hour preliminary hearing in
which each side will proceed by offers
of proof and cross-examination and the
pro offered Witnesses each side will
have one and a half hours to present
their case including
cross-examination I would think I would
get a chance to bring in my medical
Witnesses at that point I have a
pharmacist I have several medical
doctors who were all being paid to be
there to present their evidence some of
whom have seen my son in person some of
whom have not all of whom are experts
relative to tox
toxicology okay of various Medical
Products judge rules in that hearing
nope I've made my I've made up my mind
I'm not going to let you go ahead and
offer your Witnesses I've decided you're
already guilty enough that we should
proceed to the next hearing which is
scheduled almost two months later month
and a half
later my point to all of this is the
judges don't even follow their own
orders literally same judge same
courtroom same Personnel involved on all
parties and the judge who issued the
order doesn't follow his own
orders the system's
broken maybe going to children and
family law was the wrong place meaning
that this is about the judicial process
not just the children and family law
process there are people in this room
who have much greater expertise relative
to the to the courts that might be able
to weigh in on what is the right
process I think it is worthwhile
considering that there are a lot of
families who are subject to
accusations by the state government who
are now respondents who have limited
means who are put in in situations where
they're not able to
respond who should have some reasonable
rules to work with so they understand
and can expect the department who has
effectively unlimited resources to turn
in evidence ahead of time so they can
respond to it who can turn in Witnesses
ahead of time so they can respond to
it I agree with the Chairman's report
that the the language there needs work I
am fully prepared to work on that
language I think given where we are
right now and our house rules an
amendment could not be offered between
earlier this week and now I would move
to table this so that an amendment can
be drafted between various parties so
that we can discuss this at our next
session Mr Speaker is that motion in
order he was recognized to speak it is
notate for to make
ation you were recognized to speak so
making a motion is not appropriate
because then you would be speaking twice
technically and there are others to
speak
okay for what reason does a member rise
to make a
motion I'm just telling that's our
practice
rep yes thank you Mr speaker thank you
for humoring me on a longer than normal
speech I just spoke with the chairman
and he would like to share his thoughts
on the bill but we will work towards
some effort somebody can move make a
motion to table this thank you everybody
representative Mark Pearson's recognized
to speak for the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker the children
and family law committee unanimously
voted this bill in expedient to
legislate and we did it for two reasons
number one sections one and two of the
bill contradict each other section one
says the family court shall admit any
evidence or testimony in any form off by
the respondent in a court case section
two says that in all proceedings the
court shall apply the New Hampshire
Rules of Evidence I've read the book
entitled Rules of Evidence it's 280
pages long I've read it four times what
is stated in this Rules of Evidence book
gives the judge considerable latitude
and offers suggestions as to when the
judge would wisely deny the acceptance
of of certain evidence so which is it
section one the judge must admit
anything or section two the judge
following the rules of evidence may
decide not to admit something the two
sections
contradict the second reason we
unanimously voted itl has to do with
many of the complaints made to the
special committee on the Family Division
of the Circuit Court this special
committee comprises five members from
children and family law and five members
from the Judiciary
Committee in the 14 hours of public
testimony we heard many complaints that
trials were taking too long and
decisions were being pushed too far out
because too many pieces of evidence were
being admitted if the bill before us is
signed into law there's no restriction
on what the respondent in a trial may
offer how long will the trials go on for
now now another piece of evidence that
builds the case is different and my
friend I think gave some reasons why he
could argue what he wanted
heard added to the case but if it's not
adding to the case the judge should have
the right to say no the trial is going
on too
long additionally many testified before
us that the people were offering as
evidence statements that had little
probative value but were introduced
simply to tarnish the character of the
other person in other words a statement
was offered that added nothing to
helping the judge to decide guilt or
innocence but the statement was made to
drag somebody else through the mud if
the respondents profit evidence must be
accepted according to part one of this
bill we can only imagine the additional
amount of mud that will be
flinged however I believe there is
validity to what lies in the background
of this bill that is to say the
complaint a judge or two May lean too
heavily on one side or the other in
admitting or refusing to admit a piece
of
evidence that's why the amendment
offered to the other Bill about evidence
that we voted on by unanimous I think it
was Voice vote yesterday said this
if a judge denies a piece of evidence
over an objection or if the judge
refuses a piece of evidence over the
objection the judge shall place in the
trial record the reason why he or she
decided that way I will stipulate that
judges have good reasons for what they
do and if they do it is not unreasonable
to ask them to put it in writing Court
administrative supervisors would then
review knew what judges wrote in the
trial notes especially if complaints are
lodged against a certain judge
possibly they might conclude a given
judge might need some continuing
education this I believe speaks to my
friend's objections as to how his case
was handled so I'd like two things
number one I'd like this body to vote
itl and number two I will or somebody
else can move to table so my friend and
I can square a circle here and get
Justice for everybody thank you Mr
speaker now why were you Rising I'd like
to make a motion Mr Speaker go ahead I
uh moved a
table repres s moves at House Bill 499
be laid on the table you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I
this will be a division vote members
take your
seats
e
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 499 on the table and this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
vote stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
Leon have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 200 in the affirmative 164 in the
negative House Bill 499 is
unable chair recognizes a clerk Mr
Speaker pursuant to house rule
47f chairman of Finance waves the second
committee referral of House Bill
ition have
ation
for what reason doesn't member rise to
make a motion Mr Speaker go ahead uh I
would move that we put the remarks of
the last debate in the permanent journal
without objection so
ordered
the committee on criminal justice and
Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 144 FN an act restoring
firearm ownership rights to ex felons
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Jonathan stone
for the
committee for what reason does the
member rise I Rise to make a motion Mr
Speaker go ahead everybody's doing it I
move that we lay house 144 on the table
representative Roy moves at House Bill
144 be laid on the table are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I all those oppos
n yeah we're going to have to clarify
that nobody in nobody
out
seats members should be in their seats
clarification
vote
there are no pis on a clarification
seat in the voting
mode
all
right this is to clarify the previous
vote if you're in favor of laying house
bow 144 on the table press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
repres thank you
represent prudo
o'ban Representative Steven
Boyd up or down thank you
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 149 and the affirmative 209 and
negative tabling
fails representative gerhart's
recognized to speak against the
committee report
thank you everyone make this very very
quick so as some of you may know I spent
12 and a half years in federal prison
for helping an elderly couple resist
taxation because it's theft but no it
they refused to stand down and it was a
10-month standoff so I got caught up in
that but the reason up here now is that
I'm not alone there are a lot of people
in the state who are exf fallons who are
not able to get their firearm rights
back now you could say well State felons
can get their firearms right rights back
by appealing to the governor but that's
not always possible if you have
restitution so for instance a friend of
mine she lives in Manchester and she
owes over $200,000 and she cannot get
her Firearms rights back until she pays
the restitution and if we as we've said
today we we have equal rights and we
respect the rights that God gave us
which one of which is to defend our
lives our Liberty and property families
and property I believe that this is a
huge Injustice when this bill would
restore firearm rights to nonviolent
felons I understand there's people out
there that should not own guns and some
of those people are in government but
the point being is that we need to
delineate who is truly a danger and I do
don't feel that I'm a danger I think the
people that sit next me don't feel that
way maybe so I put this bill forward and
as an example to some let's say on the
other side let's think about the January
6 guys now personally I think that was a
complete entament scheme but when they
get home now they will never be able to
get their firearms race back they're
Federal felons and I can guarantee you
yeah but the house will be in order no
that's that's a fair point I get how you
feel that they're the enemies of the
system but let's think about black lives
matter do black lives really matter
if we're keeping them from ever owning
guns again you know what I mean we got
to kind of be on an equal par here we
got to kind of figure out what's
important
so and let me uh let me just run through
briefly real quickly just a couple
nonviolent Federal felonies that might
surprise you so let's say fraud that
person who commits fraud 20 years ago
should never be able to defend himself
or his family filing a false lean
against a judge or a federal official
you know like selling weed or
drugs and then we have perjury I think
most of the people in Congress have
committed perjury multip but anyway so
these people will never be able to get
their firearms right back and I think
it's hypocritical and dangerous we're
creating a two-tiered two-tiered society
with second class citizens and if you
think that somebody that you push off
into the corners is all of going to
sudden you know going to bow down to and
and want to be part of the society
they're not that's what we have in
conqueror right now all Le homeless
people run around they've created an
alternate society so I believe we need
to bring people back and I think
forgiveness is key for the January 6
people or for the the black lives matter
riers I think we got to kind of say okay
you know what we made some mistakes and
historically that's already happened so
we had Shay's Rebellion after after the
revolution some Farmers out in
Massachusetts decided they didn't feel
like paying back some suspect taxes so
they started a rebellion and afterwards
John Hancock the first governor of
Massachusetts he pardoned them all and
they were going to break into a federal
Armory and get some guns it wasn't some
kind of you know waving flags kind of
thing but forgiveness is really how
we're going to get back this whole
Bridging the Divide is not going to
happen by yelling at somebody and hoping
they're going to acques so that's why I
brought the bill forward and I'm just
doing this to get a roll call to figure
out if people really do believe in gun
rights and human rights so
thanks I call for a roll call go through
thank
you represent St representative Stones
recognized to speak speak for the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker I'm going to
make this very short concise into the
point our committee heard a lot of
testimony in regards to this issue both
at subcommittee level and regular
committee level it needs to be brought
up that currently under RSA 6515 is an
analment process that we have had
codified in our rsas for some time that
provide Provisions for felons to get
their firearms rights back if we have
due process to take someone's right away
we should have due process to return
them that gives the judge the
opportunity to look at the record look
at the individual notice all the parties
involved and then make an educated
decision at his level or her level to
reinstate Firearms rights is a byproduct
of the analment and that also applies to
misdemeanors that's how you get your
rights back to possess Firearms uh one
of the bigger issues that we have is you
cannot have a state law that oversees
federal law we we have federal laws and
convictions we do not have the authority
to anal those at the state level the
federal system has no analment mechanism
that includes the military code of
justice as well they have no mechanism
for analment we have jurisdiction over
state level offenses and that's probably
where it should be unfortunately the
feds have never decided to have analment
and with that being said I would urge
you to really think about having a due
process mechanism to reinstate
individuals rights to buiness best
Firearms it's much cleaner it keeps
everybody on the same page you just
can't I just can't fathom having oh it's
7 years in 1 minute now I can have a
firearm without going before Justice to
have my rights reinstated and to have
that taking out of the ncks screen which
everybody utilizes in addition there is
no State licensed firearm dealer it's
Federal a federal firearms dealer would
still be prohibited from doing business
with any convicted felon who's seeking
to purchase purchas a firearm unless
their state charges are annulled thank
you representative gerhart's requested a
roll call and it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
members please take your
seats
clear there
you
question before the house is a majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 144 and this is
a roll call vote representative Gerhard
is recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry if I knew that article 7 of the
state constitution is State sovereignty
and if I knew that private firearm sales
are not regulated by the federal
government then I would know that
keeping making laws keeping felons from
having firearms does no good it doesn't
stop anything when you can just simply
buy a gun from a friend or whatever else
and trust me there's a whole bunch of
people in jail that did that so thank
you representative Roy is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that it already exists the
process in Hampshire law if you are a
felon to have your firearm rights
restored if I know that if you commit a
federal felony nothing we do here today
can restore your Firearms rights and
lastly Mr Speaker if I am a Second
Amendment Advocate and I want to be
taken seriously when I defend against
legitimate laws taking our guns would I
now vote against giving them back to
people who have been convicted of
serious felonies thank
you the questions on the majority
committee
report of inexpedient to
legislate this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 297 in the affirmative 63 and the
negative the committee report is
adopted represent Roy
[Music]
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was referred House Bill
512 FN acted exempting Firearms
manufactured in New Hampshire from
federal laws and regulations consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate s jonath in
stone for the
committee chair recognize representative
Roy thank you Mr speak Motion state your
motion i' like to move to table HP 512
in the interest of saving time that is a
proper motion the motion is to table
House Bill
512 are you ready for the
question and division has been
requested members take your
seats
e
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
512 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Roy for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I want
to go home and I know that the results
of this vote are going to be the same as
the one we just took and not spend 10
more minutes would I vote to table
this chair recognize represent of Gart
for a parliamentary
inquiry if I knew that our gun rights
matter more than getting home in 5
minutes and if I knew that Alaska
Arizona Idaho South Dakota Utah
Tennessee Kansas and Wyoming passed this
exact bill and if I knew that so long as
somebody stamped ma in New Hampshire
upon a firearm it is not subject to
Federal jurisdiction and all their
nonsense I
would oppose this table thank
you the motion before us is to the table
House Bill 512 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the
vote 143 voting a 218 voting a the
tabling motion fails chair recognizes
now we're back to the committee report
of inexpedient to legislate J recognized
representative
Horgan a house will be in
order um thank you very much Mr
Speaker so I'm um rising in supported
the TL motion and hence an opposition to
the bill um the prime sponsor correctly
stated that we we'd be making special
guns as a stamped in New Hampshire on
them um
and and the idea is I think the idea is
somehow that magically exempts them from
Federal Regulations um that which I
think is uh incorrect so that's why I
support the uh committee report of
itl um this this bill is actually a
repeat of one that came up uh like 16
years ago sponsored by by uh a lot of
you may remember Dan itsa he was a prime
sponsor and he had lots of very
interesting ideas ideas are always
interesting but some of them were bad
but anyway um first and foremost this
bill is unnecessary there's no shortage
of guns in New Hampshire in
2022 uh almost 133,000 guns were sold um
so that's a lot of guns so there's
plenty of guns on the market and I'm not
really sure like uh how what how that
would be good for our state's gun
manufacturers including six hour which
uh is located the next town over for me
I live in Durham it's their Us
headquarters are in um are in
Newington um the New Hampshire gun
Market is a tiny fraction of the
nationwide market that's 17.4 million
people and a high percentage of those
17.4 million guns were sold to law
enforcement agencies the military and
other professional users who probably
would have little or no enthusiasm for
uh being able to use unregistered and
unregulated weapons so they actually um
and 6 hour I know relies primarily on
sales to that to the law enforcement the
military Market um and even ones to just
regular people but I might call amateur
gun users a lot of the sales pitches
that you can use the same cool guns that
the military or the police use um now
just picking on Sig um just because I
visited their Factory and I'm familiar
with them um they would have to set up a
SE separate production line just for
these special New Hampshire only guns
that would be very expensive and I think
it would um damage Sig existing
relationships with law enforcement and
Military markets I'm not sure like if
any of the major manufacturer sayate
would even be interested in
participating in this um it's also
unenforceable there's a very vague
definition of what constitutes a
component they can using these guns and
there's no mechanism really for
verifying that all those components are
in fact sourced from inside the state of
New Hampshire and there's also no
penalties for exporting these guns and
you just know people would carry those
guns across our state line it's it's
inevitable guns are very easily portable
commodity there's a worldwide market for
them you know it's uh these things are
going to go out of state and I I guess
we don't have much jurisdiction over
what people in other states do with
these special guns stamped uh made in
New Hampshire but uh I mean we could
probably at least put something in there
to forbid people from trying to export
them so that means uh we have no jurors
and um there's also other jur
jurisdictional issues um first of all we
simply don't have the power to
unilaterally exclude any weapon from
Federal Regulation not no matter what
magic phrase We stamp on the barrel and
also this bill's Provisions for uh
Prosecuting the member will
suspend it is way way too loud in here
the member has a right to be heard if
you have to have a conversation take it
out into the YY room remember may
continue okay the well I'm almost at the
end actually the other Juris problem is
this bill attempts to prosecute um law
enforcement other officials or even uh
government contractors who try to
enforce Federal Regulations um on these
guns and I'm sure the federal government
would uh believe that these guns are um
can be treated the same way as any other
guns that are manufactured in any other
state um and Al and finally and um so
that's a also finally a lot of probably
a vast majority of the gun users would
actually like they would like they
prefer to have a gun they can take out
of state without breaking the law they
and certainly know the the prime market
for our weapons manufacturers is uh you
know law enforcement the military they
they they like having a certain amount
of regulation in the market they might
want less than they have but um you know
they don't object to being regulated uh
so so um as I said this is an
interesting
idea if I ever WP iy those of us who
knew him there's a few room he always
had interesting ideas but most some of
them were good some of them were bad
this idea was bad a dozen years ago it's
still a bad idea so I would uh I would
urge you to do it the vamous majority of
the policy committee did earlier this or
last year late last year which is to uh
vote Yes on the itl and uh then we can
wait another dozen years to entertain
ourselves with this bill again uh later
so thank you very
much chair recogniz representative
Gart
okay less than one minute so guns can
already be made with 3D printers the
idea of trying to keep guns from going
across the state border with new laws
not going to do anything people can
print them anywhere in the back of a car
so that's pointless the the bigger issue
is having federal agents run around the
state looking for some supposed gun
violations that we don't need to have
happening we have our own police we have
our own laws and if we need new laws we
can create them here we don't need to be
going to D and having a whole bunch of
mess happening in between here and there
so that's a point and thank
you J recognize representative
janen
waves janden waves
off the motion before us is the
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator on House Bill
512 Zen of geart has requested a roll
call it is sufficiently second Ed so
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
[Music]
he's waving off
the
the motion before us is the committee
report of inexpedient to legislate house
will be in order on HB 512 this is going
to be a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
your opposer press a red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
while members present had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote 2 186 voting a 69 voting aay
committee report is
adopted okay this was
easy
Amendment
off committee on executive departments
and administration to which was referred
House Bill 518 act establishing a
commission to study revisions to
occupational regulation of phaces and
pharmacists having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation the bill
out pass with Amendment Senator JC Grody
for the
committee not yet sorry the uh committee
amendment is 24268 printed in house
record 49 Pages 80 through 85 are you
ready for the question on the committee
Amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay you eyes have it the
committee amendment is adopted pres Gro
offers floor Amendment 00
23h and is recognized to speak it is in
your seat
Pockets thank you Mr Speaker uh the
amendment corrects a um a um misstep
that was submitted in the uh Amendment
during the executive session and I I ask
the I ask you to support the floor
amendment to make this correction thank
you the motion before us is to GR four
Amendment
023 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppos nay
eyes Haven it committee amendment is
adopted the question before us now is
the committee report of ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
oppos nay the eyes have it and the
committee report is
adopted as well are you speaking to your
motion you're moving to
recomm she's going to speak
to
against
committee on Municipal and County
government to which was referred House
Bill 526
FN an act regulating the use of
temporary traffic control Personnel we
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment pres lar turot for a
committee the amendment
first chair recognizes representative
Weber
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I move
that house bill 526 be recommitted to
the
committee representative Weber moves
that house bill 526 be recommitted to
the
committee chair chair recognizes
representative
turot speak against the motion thank you
Mr Speaker I'm going to rise in
opposition to the motion to recommit as
you will notice in the calendar the bill
came out of committee with an
181 uh recommendation of ought to pass
now in 2015 there was a study committee
uh done and what came out of that
committee was a recommendation that the
municipalities be given more
discretionary authority over the use of
flaggers police details whether you used
them or not and who would
uh who would actually uh have that
authority to do it within roads and
their jurisdiction and that's important
here it's within their Juris di this is
not state
roads uh during the public hearing and
the executive session and in written
testimony we heard from municipalities
and there was a Divergence of thought
some thought uh what they had been doing
for years and years
um we didn't need a bill others said we
need the bill because we don't think we
can do it so what this became was a an
amended bill that basically clarifies
and codifies in the rsas in in many
cases what has been going on for decades
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that in a
minute so after we passed in committee
and it was published we got
some emails and calls from less than a
handful of individuals uh former and a
couple of
current police Chiefs in uh a couple
couple of the
towns now I'll talk about exactly what
what their issues
were
but all of them showed a lack of
understanding for exactly what the bill
and the amendment was
doing there were a couple of them that I
what I would call strawman
arguments so what I did is I
called my town manager or My Town
Administrator and I
said I assume the way this has worked in
in
barington is that the selectman hires a
Town
Administrator the selectman are the
municipal uh legislative
body the chief is
appointed and the town ad
administrator is the one who oversees
the
executive decisions for the
town I said tell me the chain of command
in barington how do who
decides who's if a a detail is going to
be even used if it's going to be a
police detail is it going to be flaggers
or or none at all and he said I'll get
back to you I'm not sure and when he got
back his response was the police chief
and I both see this legislation as
enabling in barington the police chief
decides and that is how it has B been
done for as long as we
know again this language
codifies that uh which has been going on
in you know many municipalities forever
and
ever so now what I want to do is talk
about a couple of
the emails or comments that I've
received the first one from a police
chief in a mediumsized city
said many of the construction Crews
actually want police officers and this
may eliminate that option that is not
the case the police chief makes the
ultimate decision if the police chief
hears from the construction Crews that
they want a detail whether that's police
detail or a a flagging detail or no
detail the police chief still has that
Authority I heard it from another uh
another one uh another medium-sized City
this limits the use of qualified or
trained police on the streets performing
the traffic deal uh details and removes
the chief's ability to determine if an
officer is appropriate again just gone
over that that's
exactly what this bill
codifies
then I got one from a a rather lengthy
one from a
former police
chief he tended he
his issue was in the case of an
emergency for fire trucks or ambulance
or cruises we need to know that
emergency Personnel would be able to get
through that's a straw Maring argument
any other town if you have a traffic
accident
or you needed somebody on site pretty
soon it's the individuals on the traffic
detail are not going to be on duty
police officers so you're going to go to
your on duty police officers and
hopefully they're going to respond
within a couple minutes to take care of
this issue that he's talking
about and then the last one I received
was this language OB obvious OB Ates
more than it clarifies who makes the
determination that the use of an officer
is needed to protect the public it
refers to the municipality is that
selectman City Council road agent dep
Department of Public's Work Director or
police chief again we've just gone
through that and ultimately it is the
police chief who will make that final
determination
now the issue that I think some people
have or one of the issues some people
have
is what happens if the police chief is
going too far using too many details or
on the flip side of that not using
enough
details that becomes the
responsibility of the Town
Administrator he's the one that's going
to make that determination and if he
fails in his job that's going to be up
to the legislative body of the
municipality so again what this bill
does is it simply codifies and puts into
the
RSA what has been
occurring for past practice and for
those towns and municipalities who
didn't think they could do this now they
can now they have it in the irsa they go
okay now we can legally do
this thank you Mr Speaker and I will ask
for a division
vote
the motion before us is to reconsider
House Bill 520 recommit recommit
recommit House Bill
526 a division has been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your
seats
ch
the motion before us is to recommit to
committee House Bill 526 this is a
division vote the chair recognizes
representative stavis for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill was retained in our committee
because it was complex and needed
further study and if I know that even at
this late date and very late hour we
feel it still needs more work because of
new information that's come to light
some of which was recited by the chair
of our committee just now and if I know
that the prudent thing to do when new
information comes to light is to take
time to consider that information when I
now press the green button and send HB
526 back to Municipal and County
government so we can do just that thank
you Mr Speaker speaker chair recognize
representative ly terot for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this bill came out of
committee with a recommendation
bipartisan recommendation of 18 to1
ought to pass as amended and if I know
that these last minute uh protests
against this bill are either a result of
strawman arguments or just incorrect
interpretation of the language would I
now press the red button on the motion
of recommit so we can bring this back
for another
motion the motion before us is a motion
to recommit to committee on house bill
526 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
to
okay if all members presing have
opportunity to vote house will attend
this state of the
vote 203 voting yay 145 voting aay House
Bill 526 is recommitted to committee on
missable and County
government what reason does a member
rise I move to lay House Bill 526 on the
table and I request a division vote no
you
can't
it's very late folks and I just read the
numbers
wrong reading the house will be in order
we still got a couple of things to
do the chair the member from U Sal Salem
representative Sweeney for the third
reading
motion resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered to third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed to the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it meet it be to meet at the call
of the chair
the question is on a third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppos nay
the eyes have it the motion is adopted
house will attend to announcements
representative lad please we have fre
announcements thank you very much Mr
Speaker for all those people education
committee our Administrative Assistant
made a packet of all the bills not all
half of them 50 bills uh for you when we
start on Monday next and we also have
our new annotated statutes for
2024 so if you want to pick your copy up
you may do so and put tags in it for
Monday thanks have a good weekend chair
recognized president P mban will
everybody please just sit for a few
minutes until we can conclude our
business here today okay everyone I have
a very
exciting announcement to make about the
I voted
stickers will that that your
constituents will receive when they vote
in the next election that at the
presidential primary there was a contest
that the Secretary of State's office
created with fourth graders throughout
the state and they have three
lovely artistic drawings that say I
voted and the the winners are Grace a
little girl named Grace from Milton a
boy named Jacob from Auburn and Ry Lynn
from Mont Vernon those are the winners
and all of the the entries are in the
tunnel that go to the lob and you can
see all of the entries if you'd like by
by visiting there thank
[Applause]
you chair recognizes the
clerk thank you Mr Speaker a few quick
announcements for you
please when you arrive in the morning I
know that sometimes we do not have all
of the uh necessary room on coat racks
and whatnot but please do not leave
coats on the benches of the anti- rooms
and uh take up space there we do have
lockers if you have we we we do have
somebody that can help with lockers if
you would like to request a locker if
you had an originally uh but please do
not pile coats hats bags Etc on the
seats out in the anti- room further seat
Pockets the only thing allowed in these
seat pockets are the items put there by
by the clerk staff or the
sergeant-at-arms team specifically
amendments calendars Etc nothing else
and this is an announcement not just for
you all but for anybody else watching
there are no documents that go into your
seat pockets in this chamber except
official documents provided by this
chamber okay uh third uh a member at the
end of the day yesterday somewhere in
division three Miss placed an entry card
I have that if you would like to come
see me uh fourth please empty your
mailboxes a lot of mail has been coming
in uh over the the last several weeks
please uh empty them at your leisure uh
and lastly a reminder only water in the
chamber only water in the chamber no
iced
coffees no frothy beverages no anything
but water thank you Mr
[Applause]
Speaker representative weeny moves at
the house stand and recess for the
purpose of an introduction of bills and
roll build amendments androll build
reports vacate motions and receiving
messages are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the house is in recess for the
call of the
chair